Blue Moon, die zwei Sprechstunden.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1, los!
Wunderschönen guten Abend, Chaos Radio auf Fritz, heute Chaos Radio 130. Bevor wir überhaupt einsteigen und erzählen, was so los ist, wir haben eine Mail bekommen, hab ich euch noch gar nicht erzählt, von einem Hörer, der sagte, er findet diesen Song total super, was das denn wäre. Da kurz angemerkt, Kraftwerk Numbers vom Album Computer Welt.
Richtig.
Das hast du gut gesagt, Jakob.
Genau genommen ist es die Variante, wo Nummern und Computer Welt in einem, also das Lied Computer Welt auf dem Album Computer Welt zusammen mit Nummern in einem Track gespielt wird.
Komm dir mal mit dem Mikrofon ein Stückchen entgegen, Tim, damit du dich da nicht so.
Das ist nett. Das Tolle ist, dass hier gleich so riesige Technik fährt.
Der ganze Tisch hebt sich irgendwie so was.
Brauche ich auch unbedingt noch für mein Podcaststudio.
Kann dir sozusagen nicht so weit entgegenkommen, weil ansonsten ist Frank wieder im Nachteil. Ja, damit ist eigentlich auch schon klar, was passiert.
Damit du geschickt angedeutet hast, wer heute im Stadio ist. Gefickt eingeschädelt.
Tim ist da, Frank ist da, mein Name ist Kranz. Wunderschönen guten Abend. Willkommen zum Chaosradio. Wie immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat zwei Stunden auf Fritz. Nummer 130. Am Anfang habe ich es erzählt. Chaosradio 130, bevor wir anfangen Kraftwerk.
Super, das ist ein Christensternchen.
Dankeschön. Womit wir im Vorfeld ganz kurz noch mal erklären müssen, das Chaosradio ist keine Beratungssendung. Also es gibt Missverständnisse. Manchmal bei 14 Mittwochs sah die Computer Heinies unterwegs. Daher kann man es schon so stehen lassen. Allerdings geht es hier nicht darum, mein E-Mail klein spinnt und meine Festplatte partitioniert sich nicht mehr. Was soll ich denn tun, weil ich jetzt nur noch einen blauen Bildschirm bekomme und ein weißes, weißes Ding ins Blink. Darum geht es weniger, sondern das Chaosradio ist eine...
Aber jetzt gar nicht.
Na manchmal muss man da einwirken, um das zu erklären. Aber das Chaosradio mit dem Chaos Computer Club ist eine fantastische Sendung, die so fast einmalig ist im gesamten Universum, die sich mit Dingen beschäftigt wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Orangensaft...
Toll, was?
Dann schenk mir doch mal einen ein.
Habe ich vorbeigekauft.
In der Zwischenzeit halt die kurze Laudatio zu Ende. Also es geht hier um Vorratsdatenspeicherung, um biometrische Reisepässe. Es geht hier um... Herzlich Dank. Es geht um die Zukunft, es geht um die Vergangenheit, es geht um Dinge aus der Welt, die ohne Strom nicht funktioniert, wie das immer so schön gesagt wird. Es geht um alles Mögliche und das Thema heute ist total fantastisch, aber dazu werde ich noch nicht sagen, weil wir jetzt mal mit einer anderen Geschichte einsteigen. Tim, jetzt ist der Ball in deiner Hälfte.
Hallo. Wir wollten ja erstmal noch ein bisschen berichten, weil es so viel Berichtenswürde gibt. Ist ja gerade eine Menge los. Womit fangen wir denn an? Keine Ahnung. Ist das nicht dein Job, da irgendwie den Ball ins Rollen zu bringen?
Ich hab den Ball in deiner Hälfte geworfen.
Ich hab gehört, ich hab gestern Fernsehen eingeschaltet.
Mensch, Tim.
Irgendso was hättest du sagen können.
Mensch, Tim, ich hab doch gestern in der ARD Plus Minus gesehen. Da ging es doch auch um ein Thema, wo ihr involviert seid.
Stimmt.
Es geht doch um das Bezahlen mit Fingerabdruck. Voll eine Geschichte, man kann in den Laden gehen und sich eine Tüte Milch und Brokkoli kaufen und das nicht mit EC-Karte zahlen, so wie früher mal, sondern neuerdings kann man das mit einem Fingerabdruck bezahlen. Man hält den Daumen oder was auch immer auf so einen komischen Scanner, der macht Pieps, sagt ja, okay, du bist Jakob Kranz, die 2 Mark 65, 2, 65 Euro, buchen wir jetzt von deinem Konto ab. Und dann kommt der Chaos Computer Club, lacht in die Finger, lacht in die Hände und sagt, hat der Kranz gar nicht gekauft. Super.
Nee, eigentlich ist es genau auch schon das Thema, dieses wow, bezahlen mit dem Fingerabdruck. Und das muss ja so sicher sein, weil ich bin ja der Einzige, der mal einen Fingerabdruck hat und da kann man ja nichts machen. Das ist ja ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal für mich. Nicht so ganz, weil man kann diese Fingerabdruckscanner, die da verwendet werden, also diese Geräte, wo man seinen Finger drauf drückt, drückt beim Bezahlen an der Kasse, die dann erkennen, dass das irgendwie Frank Rosengart und der will jetzt hier bezahlen, die kann man ziemlich leicht überlisten. Und die Geräte, die da speziell in diesen Supermarkt, nennen wir den Namen mal nicht, das ist eine Supermarktkette im Süddeutschland, die den verwenden.
Auf blau, auf gelb.
Genau, die sind ja ganz besonders anfällig. Generell betrifft das aber eigentlich alle Systeme. Es gibt irgendwie kein System, was wir bisher da nicht überlisten konnten. Und ja, wir haben halt gezeigt, wie es mit ein bisschen basteln, mit ein bisschen Holzleim und ein bisschen...
Holzleimfolie, Cola-Dickel.
Ja, und es ist auch ein total alter Hut.
Ich meine, das haben wir schon vor drei, vier Jahren schon.
Da gab es schon das Video. So, plus die Scheiße funktioniert halt immer noch.
Und sie wollten teils nicht glauben und irgendwie bisher hat es noch keiner im großen Stil gemacht und irgendwie rief dann halt auch mal die ARD an. Ja, wir haben noch so eine Idee. Da haben wir gedacht natürlich, na klar, da sind wir gern dabei. Und dann kam der Reporter zu uns vorbei und hat dann einen Fingerabdruck mitgebracht von seinem Kollegen.
Auf einem Saftglas?
Und dann haben wir gesagt, okay, kein Problem.
Krieg ich deswegen von dir eigentlich in so ein Saftglas krediert?
Genau, kam gleich in die Sammlung.
Und es wurde ein bisschen gebastelt und dann haben wir diesen Fingerabdruck nachgebaut quasi. Das heißt, man hat dann so ein kleines Stückchen, ja so ein Film, also so einen kleinen, ja so eine dünne Schicht wie ein zweites Stück Haut, was man sich dann auf den Finger klebt. Und damit geht man dann fleißig einkaufen.
Genau, das hat super funktioniert. Und jetzt haben die wirklich einen echt schönen Fernsehbericht gekleidet. Also wirklich schon lange nicht mehr so eine gut produzierte Geschichte gesehen.
Und den kann man sich jetzt noch angucken.
Ja, gibt es bei der ARD auch online.
Gibt es bei der ARD. Wir haben natürlich auch eine Pressenspiegelkopie bei uns. Übrigens im Chaosradio Podcast Network. Da gibt es ja auch mehrere Feats. Neben Chaosradio gibt es etwas, das heißt Dossier Kaotik. Und da schneiden wir eigentlich immer alles zusammen, was halt so über uns berichtet wird in der weiten Fernsehlandschaft oder auch mal in der Radiolandschaft. So auch dieser Bericht wie auch viele andere Sachen und auch das alte Fingerabdruckvideo bei Chaos TV. Könnt ihr da alles finden?
Also wir halten fest, irgendwelche Menschen sagen, mit dem Fingerabdruck bezahlen ist total super. A verdient eine Firma, die die Scanner herstellt, damit ein Haufen Geld. B muss sich natürlich der Supermarkt nicht mehr damit rumschlagen, dass irgendwelche EC-Karten nicht mehr funktionieren und so weiter und so fort. Aber dieses immer wieder rausgestellte Sicherheitsfeature, dass der Fingerabdruck nur meiner ist und den hat sonst keiner, das war in einer knappen Stunde mit so ein bisschen Baumarkt. Und ganz kurz den Satz zu Ende. Und wenn wir das jetzt weiter denken auf biometrischen Reisepass, auf das, was da alles noch kommen mag, dann möchte man sich das alles gar nicht ausdenken.
Na klar, es funktioniert natürlich genau so an der Grenzkontrolle, auch wie im Supermarkt. Und das erzählen wir auch seit Jahren schon, dass diese Biometriepässe eigentlich nichts bringen, sondern im Gegenteil die ganze Sache noch viel, viel unsicherer machen. Weil wenn dieser Fingerabdruck erst mal vom Computer als okay erkannt wird, dann wird auch kein Beamter an der Kontrolle, an der Grenze, und wird dann noch mal sagen, ja im Moment, also jetzt schauen wir noch mal genau nach, und er sagt, Fingerabdruck stimmt, zack, durchgehen, alles klar.
Es ist halt die alte Geschichte des blinden Vertrauens in Technologie. Also viele Leute glauben immer, wenn sie nur möglichst neue Technologie nehmen, dann wird das auch besonders gut sein. Bloß erstens ist neue Technologie in zwei Jahren immer alt und zweitens ist das sowieso Quatsch. Weil gerade neue Technologie hat einfach das Problem, dass sich noch niemand wirklich damit auseinandergesetzt hat. Umso neuer etwas ist, umso weniger Erfahrung gibt es damit und umso weniger kann man davon behaupten, es sei jetzt irgendwie sicher.
Ja, aber du kannst den Leuten das wunderbar neue Geräte kaufen, weil drauf steht neu.
Ja, na sicher, aber es ist ja was vollkommen...
Stichwort UMTS.
Es ist aber was vollkommen anderes, als ob ich das jetzt für meinen Privatgebrauch verwende und dann funktioniert es oder nicht. Oder ob man halt komplette Gesellschaftssysteme so umbaut, dass sie eben auf das Funktionieren dieser Technik... Ja, also wenn diese Technik nicht funktioniert, dass es dann halt einfach hops geht. Bestes Beispiel jetzt wieder die Sache mit den Wahlcomputern, Teil 2 in Hamburg, wo sie jetzt versuchen oder versucht haben, muss man ja glücklicherweise sagen, ein neues System einzuführen, das nennt sich Wahlstifte. Auch dazu gab es vor kurzem auf Chaos Radio Express einen sehr ausführlichen Podcast zum Nachhören. Die Geschichte lief kurz gesagt so, sie wollten halt neues Wahlsystem einführen, um ihr neues kompliziertes Wahlgesetz besser auszählen zu können. Und haben sich dann halt diese blöden Business-Kamera-Stiftteile, die so für Productivity-Anwendungen gemacht sind, ausgedacht.
Wobei die eigentlich eine coole Technologie ist auch.
Ist eine coole Technologie.
Aber es ist halt irgendwie eine wahnsinnig komplexe Technologie. Und das versteht sich auch niemand so richtig.
Genau, das ist etwas, was wir nachher bejubeln werden. Aber in dem Zusammenhang ist es einfach totaler Quatsch, weil das einfach so viele andere Sektoren hat, dass man überhaupt gar nicht mehr im Aufzählen zu Ende kommt. Und das ist jetzt nun, Gott sei Dank, durch Mediendruck, der unter anderem auch durch uns ausgelöst wurde, durch das Veröffentlichen von verschiedenen Angriffsszenarien, ist dieses System jetzt zurückgezogen worden, weil sie einfach eingesehen haben, dass es einfach nicht genug Unterstützung dafür gibt. Es ist noch nicht ganz raus. So Thüringen denkt jetzt auch noch drüber nach. Der Teufel wird immer wieder zurückkommen. Aber eigentlich ist das alles Tünne. Und das werden sie auch irgendwann einsehen.
Der Teufel, der noch Teufel ist, später super und danach Tünne führt, ist Stichwort und Thema der Sendung.
Ja, ein bisschen. Genau. Kommen wir doch mal zur Sendung. Also leckerer Orangen, übrigens. Wir haben das übrigens alles jetzt auch mal vorangestellt, um auch klarzumachen. Wir haben halt neben Chaosradio gibt es eben auch noch Chaosradio Express. Das sind eben Podcasts, die die Sachen noch sehr viel mehr in die Tiefe zwingen, wo halt einfach die Technik voll zum Spielen kommt. Da schaut ihr einfach mal auf Chaosradio CCC.de. Und was hier auch noch mal erwähnt werden sollte, ist, dass Chaosradio auch einen Blog hat unter Blog Chaosradio CCC.de. Da könnt ihr auch dann zu dieser Sendung kommentieren. Und natürlich haben wir schon seit längerem das Wiki, wo man immer schön noch so Sachen nachtragen kann. Sendungsnotizen, Fragen vorab und so weiter.
Alles erreichbar von Chaosradio.ccc.de.
Genau, aber jetzt haben wir ja hier in den letzten Monaten mit Chaosradio haben wir ja eine ganze Menge geschwatzt über Überwachungsstaat, hin Videoüberwachung, überall Vorratsansprechung. Vorratsansprechung, du hast das ja vorhin schon alles runtergeknackert und das ist ja auch alles richtig und super. So, manchen war es schon ein bisschen zu viel. Ich meine, dieses Jahr war uns auch ein bisschen zu viel, weil was von der Politik so auf uns zugerollt wurde.
Was könnt ihr denn dafür, wenn die eine hirnreisige Idee nach der anderen haben?
So, aber wir haben ja eigentlich immer die Tradition hier bei Chaosradio gehabt, dass wir auch ein Thema ein bisschen wechseln, dass wir eben jetzt nicht nur immer nur so die politische, gesellschaftspolitische Seite beleuchten, sondern dass wir eben auch zum Ausdruck bringen wollen, dass wir eben auch Spaß mit Technik haben, dass das ja eigentlich auch so der Ursprung ist, warum wir eigentlich hier alle auch im ZZ zusammengefunden haben und das, was uns eben abgesehen von unseren gesellschaftspolitischen Vorstellungen eben auch verbindet. So einfach dieses naive, spielerische, das, was eben auch ein Hacker eben auch ausmacht.
Und hochgeschätzte Leute an den Radios oder an den Computern oder Telefonen, wo ihr auch mal das hört gerade, ich kann es bestätigen, Tim und Frank haben schon mal gelacht. Die haben schon Humor.
Das ist nicht das, was ich behaupte.
Kokolores.
Na ja, ich meine, wir haben schon eine Menge Spaß. Und mit Technik und am Gerät. Jetzt haben wir halt so ein bisschen über nachgedacht. Oh Gott, November, was machen wir denn? So der Kongress steht vor der Tür. Wir müssen jetzt einfach auch mal einen anderen Blickpunkt aufmachen. Und da ist mir ein schönes Zitat eingefallen. Genau, bin ich darauf hingewiesen worden. Aber die Idee für die Sendung hatte ich schon vorher von Mr. Clark, der so 2001 geschrieben hat und so. Er hat irgendwann mal so schön gesagt, jede hinreichend fortschrittliche Technologie ist von Magie nicht zu unterscheiden.
Ein Wunderwerk der Technik. Wie funktioniert es? Keiner weiß es, aber alle finden es toll.
Ja, und vor allem, wenn die Technik also fortgeschritten ist, oder sagen wir mal, wenn sie ausreichend neu ist, dann kennen wir einfach alle diesen Effekt so. Oh weia, wie cool ist denn das jetzt? Ich fühle mich wie in so einem Science-Fiction-Film. Man hat auf einmal das erste Mal so Kontakt mit irgendetwas und man weiß irgendwie kaum ein Mensch macht das so, wie ich das jetzt gerade getan habe. Die meisten haben wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal eine Ahnung, dass es das gibt, geschweige denn, dass irgendjemand Zugriff dazu hat. Und ich benutze das jetzt auch. Und auf einmal transformiert das auch die Möglichkeiten, die ich habe, dermaßen woanders hin. Und dann hat man irgendwie diesen Highlander-Effekt. Irgendwie der Himmel reißt auf, so ein Lichtstrahl kommt von oben runter geschossen und man duscht sich da so zehn Sekunden lang drin und fällt dann irgendwie wieder auf den Boden und fühlt sich einfach cool.
Was war denn dein letzter Highlander-Effekt?
Mein letzter Highlander-Effekt?
So der aktuellste, also bevor wir anfangen über Datasetten und solche Geschichten zu reden.
Das war...
Oder den Walkman.
Das ist zwei Wochen her oder drei. Ich saß so nachts noch so ein bisschen an meinem Schreibtisch und daddelt an diesem und jedem rum und auf einmal, ich hatte dann irgendwie so meinen Skype angelassen und dann plapperte mich eine Freundin an und die wohnt jetzt in Kolumbien. Da wohnt sie schon seit einiger Zeit. Das heißt, ich hab sie schon seit langer Zeit nicht mehr gesehen. Ja, hallo und so weiter.
Also du sitzt da, schreibst, dein Messenger macht plönk, das ist online.
Genau, machen einfach plönk, hallo, so. Und dann meint sie so, ja, sie hat jetzt auch ein MacBook, irgendwie wollen wir nicht Video machen. Ich so rataratarata, stimmt ja, Skype hat ja auch Video. Hab ich noch nie gemacht. Also wusste, dass es das gibt und auf Videotelefoniere hab ich natürlich schon mal gemacht, aber nicht mit Kolumbien. Und dann zack, angeschaltet, funktionierte einfach sofort. Ich guckte sie irgendwie an, hab sie irgendwie gesagt, was weiß ich, zwei Jahre nicht mehr gesehen, war schon mal total toll. Dann plapperten wir so über dieses und jenes und so. Ja, und du kennst ja meine Wohnung noch nicht. Soll ich sie dir mal zeigen? So, und dann nahm sie ihren Laptop, also ihr MacBook, drehte den um, so Kamera voraus und latschte durch die ganze Wohnung und zeigte mir das und natürlich hatte sie also WLAN bei sich zu Hause und ich natürlich auch und zeigte mir irgendwie ihre Wohnung. Ja, hier ist irgendwie die Küche und der Flur und so weiter. Und meinte, das ist ja cool irgendwie so. Und sie kannte meine neue Wohnung auch noch nicht. Also hab ich meinen MacBook genommen und das Ganze nochmal gemacht. Und irgendwann standen wir dann beide im Badezimmer jeweils, das MacBook auf dem Badezimmergespiegel gerichtet. So und jetzt klackern wir nach. Also ich guckte auf meinen Badezimmerspiegel. Darin sah ich mich mit meinem MacBook. In diesem MacBook sah ich sie in Kolumbien mit einem MacBook in der Hand, vor dem Badezimmerspiegel.
Wo man in dem Moment überlegt, wie viele Kilometer geht es jetzt hin und her?
Genau. Und ich sah mich wieder da drin und da war sie wieder da drin.
Und da war der Heilender Lichtstreu.
Und das war genau dieser Heilender Lichtstreu, wenn man so... So du lebst die Zukunft. Also ja, es ist jetzt keine total unmögliche Installation, aber ich fand das einfach mal so cool, wie man mit so einer simplen Technologie eigentlich das machen kann. Und ja, das war mein letzter Moment.
Was... Habt ihr so Momente erlebt, wo euch... Das Bild ist super, ich möchte es gerne benutzen in der Sendung, wenn ich darf, Tim. Der Heilender Lichtstrahl packte, traf und ihr sagtet, das ist eigentlich 20 Jahre weiter voraus und ich bin gerade Teil einer technischen Entwicklung, die mich total flasht, die mich beeindruckt, wo ich glaube, dass das in absehbarer Zeit noch viel größer wird, dass das viele Menschen benutzen werden. Sei es irgendwie der MP3-Player, sei es das Internet, sei es das Mobiltelefon, sei es der CD-Player im Auto, sei es das mobile mit sich rumtragbare Navi, was euch sagt, wo ihr euch befindet, obwohl ihr auf eurer eigenen Haustür steht, alles solche Dinge. Darüber wollen wir heute reden und da uns einen wunderbaren Abend im Chaosradio machen. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Telefonnummer bei Fritz, 0331 für Potsdam und dann 70 97 110. Angerufen hat Nils aus Berlin. Stimmt das? Hallo Nils, guten Abend. Du bist kein Mädchen, deswegen darf ich dich ohne Scheu fragen, wie alt du bist. 25. Was war dein letzter Technik-Flash?
Mein letzter Technik-Flash, also im letzten echtem Technik-Flash hatte ich als erstes das iPhone in der Hand hatte, als es noch nicht in Deutschland raus war.
Du bist nicht, aber bist du deswegen in die Welt gefahren, um es zu sehen oder hat es andere Gründe gehabt?
Ich bin deswegen nicht in die Welt gefahren. Ich bin einfach nur zum nächsten Grafes gefahren, aber das war so der letzte Technik-Flash.
Und was hat dich darin so geflasht?
Das Interface war einfach mal anders.
Das heißt, du hast ein Gerät ohne Tasten, tippst ein bisschen, wischt ein bisschen drauf rum und...
Das jetzt nicht, ich weiß nicht.
Die ganze Bedienung, mit dem, dass sie das Accelerometer richtig eingesetzt haben und also wie es sich angefühlt hat, das war einfach anders.
Kann ich voll nachvollziehen.
Ein Accelerometer für die Nichtwissenden ist diese.
Ein Beschleunigungs-Sensor, der halt merkt, wenn du das Ding drehst, damit kannst du von Portrait auf Landscape umschalten und so.
Das ist also das Bild von Hochkant auf Querformat sich dreht.
Schalten wir dann auch Mikrofon und Lautsprecher um? Das ist auch die Geschichte, dass die Leute, die sich besperrt haben, das nicht so.
Und wann hast du das erste Mal einen Computer in der Hand gehabt?
Das erste Mal einen Computer, oh Gott, da war ich vier oder fünf.
Ah, und wann hast du das erste Mal?
Vier und zwei 86er, da war ich neun oder so.
Und wann hast du das erste Mal begriffen, was ein Computer ist?
Ich glaube, da war ich auch schon so fünf oder sechs, weil mein Bruder irgendwie angefangen hatte, dann zu programmieren.
Und ich meine, wenn man jetzt so jung an einen Computer rankommt, hat man dann nur noch dieses Feeling, dass das irgendwie die Zukunft ist? Oder ist das so selbstverständlich, dass man dann irgendwie so, dass so wie Kochlöffel und Kaffeemaschine?
Also Computer sind relativ normal. Es gibt halt immer mal wieder, es gibt immer mal wieder so Sachen, wo man so ein Flash hat. Also bei verschiedenen Technologien finde ich. Was halt auch war, ich weiß nicht, jetzt so als ich das erste Mal irgendwie Mac OS 10 gesehen hatte, zum Beispiel. Also mit mit Exposeon und dem ganzen Drum und Dran. Also wo ich es mal richtig in der Hand hatte und nicht nur irgendwie im Laden stehen sehen. Das fand ich auch schon anders. Also vor allen Dingen, wenn man vorher Windows und irgendwie XLS hatte. Und oder keine Ahnung, als in Japan war, Handys vor drei Jahren, wo sie dann irgendwie UMTS schon richtig weit verbreitet war. GPS im Handy auch nicht wirklich unnormal. Oder Fernsehen gab es dann auch schon die ersten Modelle im Handy. Und das war einfach mal anders.
Auf den Punkt würde ich gerne noch ein bisschen rumreiten, wenn du gerade sagst, du bist mehr oder weniger mit dem Computer groß geworden. 26, 286 und so ist für dich vollkommen normal gewesen, als du klein warst mit 5, 6, den ersten Kontakt mit dem Computer. Aber mit 25 hast du wie viele andere auch schon irgendwie den ersten Impact von Mobiltelefonen miterlebt, wo Leute auf der Straße stehen und miteinander telefonieren.
Ja, mein Bruder hatte dieses Grüne von E+, wo sie im Endeffekt noch kostenlos waren.
Ja, da haben wir eben auch gerade sehr ausführlich drüber diskutiert vor der Sendung. Da haben wir noch was zu erzählen.
Ja, das heben wir uns als Bomben auf.
Sag dir denn was, wie hieß der Anrufer noch gleich? Nils, sagt dir E-Gate was?
Mir sagt was.
Also ich hab's selber nicht erlebt. Ich glaub, ich hab's in einem Chaosradio oder einem Chaosradio Express ging's ja mal intensiver drüber, dass dann auch irgendwie die E-Plus Server wohl abgeschmiert sind wegen...
Ja, wir hatten da richtig viel Spaß mit dem ersten SMS.
Ich glaub, das hab ich mit Tobias im Chaosradio Express zur digitalen Telefonie war das dabei, genau.
Ja, das war großartig. Vielleicht gibt's noch irgendwelche Sachen, die jetzt so gar nicht mit diesem Computerbereich zu tun haben, wo du sagst, boah, das ist jetzt aber trotzdem nochmal irgendwie die technische Erleuchtung gewesen oder so.
Die technische Erleuchtung?
Also mir ging's so, mein erstes Foto mit einer Digitalkamera war einfach auch so, boah, super, das ist jetzt sofort da, ich kann es auf dem Display sehen und selbst für mich jemand, der wirklich viel mit Technik zu tun hat, war das aber nochmal so ein Aha-Erlebnis.
Ich glaub, mein erster Text ist ein Unicode mit verschiedenen Zeichengelässen.
Sie sind.
Also, so komisch es sich anhört, ich studiere ja Panologie und da hat man mit den Zeichengelässen zu tun.
Das stimmt, das ist natürlich eine normale Leuchtung, wenn du einfach was tippen kannst. Und ich mein, man stellt sich vor, eine Schreibmaschine, da gibt es halt einfach Buchstaben drauf. Und so auf einer normalen Computertastatur. Und wer von uns jetzt so nicht normal damit zu tun hat, mit anderen Zeichen setzen. Also, dass man einfach andere Zeichen als unsere gewohnten Zeichen schreibt. Das ist natürlich toll.
Das man relativ einfach auch eingeben kann. Ich mach auch Koreanisch und da hat man noch eine andere Schrift dort. Und wenn man den ganzen Kram auf einmal kombinieren kann, das ist schon ziemlich cool, weil das lange Zeit einfach nicht ging. Also, wenn ich an meine ersten Probleme, also meine erste Zeit in Linux denke, was ist da für ein Kampfer oder auch ein Windows, die da, ja, Microsoft ist da, meistens relativ weit. Das ist einer der wenigen Sachen, die so halbwegs richtig hinbekommen. Das ist ziemlich weit, also das war schon ziemlich cool, dass es auf einmal ganz einfach ging.
Gibt es denn so Dinge, die du dir für dein Leben als Student von koreanisch und japanisch-japanologie oder sonst was wünschst, wo du sagst, das müsste jetzt mal jemand erfinden, weil das macht alles einfacher?
Wow, du lebst wirklich in der Zukunft.
Technische Entwicklung, vielen Dank, ihr könnt aufhören zu forschen, fahrt an den Strand.
Also das einzig coole wäre vielleicht noch, wenn die Geräte sich vereinen würden. Also ich hab mir jetzt gerade ein elektronisches Wörterbuch gekauft für knapp 300 Euro mit Handschrifteingabe und allem Drum und Dran. Und es wäre cool, wenn, also ich hab einen Sharp Zaurus, da konnte ich dann irgendwie mir das japanische Rom nehmen und die Handschrifteingabe da rausziehen und da drin installieren. Und da hatte ich zwar schon so ein bisschen PDA und ein japanisches Wörterbuch, aber es wäre irgendwie cool, dass so in einem Smartphone drin zu haben. Also dass das mal alles kombiniert ist und ich irgendwie auch multilinguale Wörterbücher habe.
Und wenn das Ding dann auch noch telefonieren kann, deine 200 Gigabyte Musik mit dir rumtragen kann und du auch noch notfalls Fernsehen gucken kannst, dann wäre der Hammer, oder? Und es darf natürlich nicht so groß sein, dass man einen eigenen Anhänger braucht.
Ja, dann gucken wir dich nicht, aber zum Beispiel so was, also ein normales Smartphone oder so was wie das iPhone hat den passenden Formpakt, das hat die Handschrifteingabe. Das liefert also die Grundlage zumindest schon mal mit. Und da müsste halt nur noch mehr an Technik rein, oder nicht mehr an Technik rein, aber Software seitlich.
Na gut, lassen Sie sich so viel über die Zukunft, die noch kommt, philosophieren, sondern über die, die wir schon erlebt haben.
Nils, danke für den Anruf. Und wunderbare Ideen, schönen Abend nach Berlin. Wir machen jetzt gleich die Nachrichten und danach ist Martin zum Beispiel dran und auch Jens. Es geht um so Dinge wie Sinclair ZX81.
Wow, aber wir müssen vorher noch das E-Gate erklären.
E-Gate, du hast, ähm...
Machen wir das noch hin.
Ich nehme mir noch einen Schluck von deinem großartigen Orangen.
Kriegen wir das noch vor der Sendung hin?
Ich weiß es nicht, also dann fangen wir einfach an.
Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, jetzt setzt mich aber unter Druck.
Dann machen wir es nach und nach.
Also, was er eben erwähnt hat, ist ja die Einführung von SMS in Deutschland ist durch...
Durch E+, damals passiert. Genau. Das waren die ersten, die haben gesagt, okay, wir wissen noch nicht genau, ob das funktioniert, ob das überhaupt jemand nutzt.
Will das überhaupt jemand?
Wir wissen gar nicht, ob die Telefone das so richtig können. Und überhaupt mit den Tasten, das macht ja eh niemand. Aber hier ist es, macht mal erstmal. Okay, ein paar Leute bei uns im CCC, die haben das gemacht. Wir haben einen Server aufgesetzt quasi, wo wir also einen Rechner hatten, wo wir ein Telefon angeschlossen haben, über so einen Datenkabel. Und haben dann eine kleine Software für gebaut. Eine Software, die, wenn eine SMS ankommt, die aus dem Telefon ausliest, die irgendwie verarbeitet, was damit tut und entsprechend wieder reagiert. Und dann vielleicht auch die eine oder andere SMS wieder raus schickt an andere Leute. So, und dann ging es so los, dass wir im Prinzip so ein kleines Chat-System gebaut haben. Das heißt, man konnte sich da auf irgendwie so Listen subscriben, also eintragen, wo dann Leute eine SMS hingeschickt haben. Und die wurde dann an alle anderen Teilnehmer wieder verteilt. Also sowas wie eine Mailing-Liste, aber per SMS. Kostet ja alles nichts, egal, macht ja nichts. Und dann ging es so los, dass sich zum Beispiel Leute eine Liste erzeugt haben, wo sich die Fahrkartenkontrolleure in der Berliner U-Bahn jeweils mal zugeschickt haben und vorgewarnt haben. Weil die Berliner U-Bahn waren auch die Ersten, die Mobilfunknetze verfügbar gemacht haben. Das war die Tunnel.
Genau, die E-Plus-Ding haben mich auch in die Tunnel. Das war nämlich das Grüne.
So, und dann haben sich die Leute da Warnungen geschickt, von wegen irgendwie U8-Hermannplatz Richtung Norden. Da sind jetzt grad die Kontrollen. Und es wurden riesen Dings, wurden Selbstläufer. Die Leute haben sich darum gerissen, da auch aufgenommen zu werden, sich eintragen zu lassen. Und zum Schluss hatten wir dann ein paar tausend User drauf und haben ungefähr 80.000 Kurzmitteilungen pro Tag verschickt. E-Plus war da überhaupt gar nicht von begeistert, weil sie wollten uns auch keine Datenleitung geben, keine direkte Anbindung an deren Zentrale. Und so mussten wir ein Telefon nach dem anderen kaufen, was denn in der Berliner West City dann stand und leider auch das gesamte Telefonnetz da, also zumindest das SMS-Netz, da platt gemacht hat.
Das E-Geld hat 90 Prozent des gesamten SMS-Verkehrs von E-Plus.
Aber das war schon großartig. Keine Ahnung, sie haben mal so 200 SMS pro Tag geschrieben oder so. E-Plus hat auch den Fehler gemacht, sie hatten auf die ersten Telefone vier Jahre Garantie gegeben. Und mit einer 24 Stunden Austauschgarantie, das heißt man hat da angerufen, meine Tastaturmatte ist schon wieder kaputt. Ich brauch eine neue.
Gut, wir kommen morgen vorbei.
Seid ihr schuld daran, dass SMS jetzt Geld kosten?
Die letzte Fritz nach der Talente war richtig groß, aber leider nicht groß genug, für alle, die nicht mehr reinkamen. Deswegen ist die Fritznacht der Talente im nächsten Jahr noch größer. Und ganz nebenbei noch besser, härter, bunter, schöner, mutiger, lauter, kurioser, einzigartiger, außergewöhnlicher und talentierter. Fritz präsentiert die vierte Fritznacht der Talente. Samstag, 12. April 2008. Solang es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten überall, wo es Karten gibt. Und mehr Infos?
Die vierte Fritz nach der Talente.
So, und niemand soll behaupten, wir hätten es gleichzeitig bescheid gesagt.
Mit Matthias Sachow.
In der neuen PISA Studie schneiden deutsche Schüler offenbar besser ab. Eine spanische Lehrerzeitung berichtete, sie liegen beim Umweltwissen und in Naturwissenschaften in der Spitzengruppe, nämlich auf Platz 13 von insgesamt 57 Staaten. Bei der PISA Studie 2003 war Deutschland noch auf Platz 18, allerdings kann man beide Tests nicht vergleichen, weil die Aufgabenstrukturen anders sind. Nach der gestrigener Ostkonferenz in Annapolis haben US-Präsident Bush, Palästinenser Präsident Abbas und der israelische Ministerpräsident Olmert heute im Weißen Haus symbolisch die neuen Friedensverhandlungen gestartet. Gestern war vereinbart worden, dass die detaillierten Verhandlungen am 12. Dezember beginnen sollen. Die Arabische Liga rief dazu auf, den neuen Friedensverhandlungen eine Chance zu geben. Mit einem Bußgeldkatalog wollen Bund und Länder den Jugendschutz verbessern. Wer Tabak, Alkohol oder Gewaltvideos an Jugendliche verkauft, muss in Zukunft mit bis zu vierstelligen Geldstrafen rechnen. Das sagte Bundesfamilienministerin von der Leyen heute. In Gaststätten und Tankstellen soll es Schwerpunktkontrollen geben. Die umstrittenen Testkäufe von Jugendlichen will die Ministerin nicht mehr bundesweit regeln. Der Bundesnachrichtendienst muss einem Journalisten, den er bespitzelt hatte, Akteneinsicht gewähren. Das hat das Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig entschieden. Der BND hatte den Redakteur der Berliner Zeitung ebenso wie andere Journalisten überwacht, um herauszubekommen, woher sie interne Informationen des Dienstes erhalten hatten. Die Affäre war vor zwei Jahren bekannt geworden. Zum Fußball. In der Champions League spielen gerade zwei deutsche Teams. Schalke 04 spielt in Valencia. Hier steht es 0 zu 0. Werder Bremen führt zu Hause gegen Real Madrid mit 3 zu 2. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Frankfurt 0 Grad, Cottbus und Angermünde 1 Grad, Potsdam, Neurupien und Wittenberge 2 Grad und auch in Berlin 2 Grad zurzeit. In der Nacht bleibt es trocken. Die Temperaturen sinken bis auf minus 4 Grad. Es kann glatt werden zum Teil. Morgen gibt es erstmal viele Wolken, ein bisschen Sonne zwischendurch. Zum Abend hin ist dann Regen oder Sprühregen möglich. Und das bei Temperaturen zwischen 3 und 6 Grad. A12. Berliner Regen Richtung Frankfurt oder. Zwischen Raststädte Wiegen der Hellen Süd und dem Grenzübergang haben wir Stau. Und nochmal die A12 Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Friedersdorf und Dreieck Spree aus steht ein kaputter Lkw. Hier kommt zu Behinderung. Ansonsten euch überall eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 1? Dann Fritz in der Prägnitz.
Und es hat Zoom gemacht. Das Untertitel, da der Untertitel vom Chaosradio 130. Tim, Frank, Jakob im Studio, ihr habt ein Telefon 0331 77 97 110. Es geht um den von Tim so wunderbar beschriebenen Flash, den man kriegt so heilendermäßig, wenn aus dunklem Himmel ein Blitz dich erhält und du sagst, so was geht?
Geile technische Wurst.
Es ist ja der Hammer.
Ja, Living The Future ist das Stichwort.
Ich hab's bildlich gemacht, jetzt war dein Einwurf dabei.
Ja, Living The Future haben wir das genannt. Das kommt aus so einem anderen Moment, den hatte ich irgendwie vor Gott, wie lange ist das jetzt her? Zwei Jahre, als das große Katrina-Desaster in New Orleans losging. Und ich hatte gerade irgendwie ein bisschen zu viel Zeit und hab dann wie so ein Blöder alles wahrgenommen, was aus New Orleans kam. Es ging dann so weit, dass ich sogar den damals im Internet live übertragenen lokalen Fernsehsender mir die ganze Zeit angeguckt hab. So also es strömte einfach die ganze Zeit auf mich ein. Und da kam es halt, dass ein geplanter Referent des davor stattgefundenen Kongresses, der aber nicht kommen konnte, angekündigt hat in seinem Blog, dass er da hinfährt. So und ich hatte mich irgendwie so aus Interesse an ihm subscribt. Das ist der Jakob Applebaum, der ist dann nach Houston gefahren, hat da eine Radiostation in dieser Halle da aufgebaut und so weiter. Und ist dann aber weiter nach New Orleans. Und ich habe ihn halt kurz angechattet und er schattete so zurück. Und dann artete das so aus, dass er mir dann immer mehr beschrieb, was er denn jetzt eigentlich tat. Und ich war also relativ gut darüber informiert, wo er sich jetzt gerade befindet und was so sein nächster Task ist. Und dann zwei Tage später kam ich gerade so im Club rum, irgendwie blingend, geht bei mir wieder ein Fenster auf, auf dem Bildschirm. So ja, da war er wieder. Ob ich denn eben einen Quicktime Streaming Server irgendwie organisieren könnte, mal ganz schnell, er bräuchte jetzt mal einen. So ich so mal nachdenken und es ging ja auch ganz fix, weil Dennis bei uns im Club, der hat irgendwie immer einen rumliegen, eine Hosentasche dabei, eine Hosentasche, der saß oben, ich hochgestürmt, hatte ich so alles kein Problem, irgendwie fünf Minuten hast du das. So und dann habe ich ihm diesen Login drüber gegeben. Dann habe ich überhaupt erst geschneit, was passiert war. Er ist mitten nach New York, Niens, reingefahren, aber so südlich vom Fluss, wo es halt nicht so überschwemmt war und ist dort in so ein Haus eingekehrt, wo so ein ehemaliger Black Panther Aktivist sein Haus kurzum in so ein Hilfstzentrum umgewandelt hat. Und sie sind da halt mit einer Wagenladung Computer hingefahren, um dort ein Internetcafé aufzumachen, also sozusagen den Leuten die Möglichkeit geben, zu kommunizieren, weil die natürlich all ihre Verwandten gesucht haben und Informationen brauchten. Das waren sehr coole Aktionen und sie sind dann da aufgeschlagen an dem Abend und es gab aber gerade keinen Strom. Strom war halt einfach ausgefallen, kann man sich ja ganz gut vorstellen. Eine der einzigen Infrastrukturen, die in New Orleans überhaupt gut funktionierte, das war dieses EVDO-Funknetzwerk. Das ist so eine, ja, nicht so standardisierte, ich weiß nicht, das ist ein privater Standard, weiß jetzt gerade nicht, EVDO, kann man nachschlagen. Und das funktionierte da. Das heißt, es gab mit speziellen EVDO-Karten Internet. Und er hatte seinen Laptop dabei, hatte so eine Karte da drin. Es gab keinen Strom, aber das Ding hatte noch Akku. Dann hat er so eine Kamera dran gehabt. Naja, und machte dann halt so iChat irgendwie und beplappert miteinander. Und dann hab ich ihm irgendwie den Streaming-Server gemacht und dann konnte er dann halt in dem Moment, so nach zehn Minuten, nachdem er mich gefragt hat, raussenden, hat irgendwie über Blogs die URL verteilt und sein Stream, wie er da so mitten in New Orleans im dunklen Haussitz, so quasi von Katastrophe umgeben, ja, und dass es auch nur eine Steckdose gab, aus der Strom gab, wohnte dann halt einfach von ganz vielen Leuten live empfangen werden. Und wir chatteten danach so noch so eine Weile rum und so irgendwie, wie unglaublich doch dieser Moment jetzt gewesen wäre, und dann meinte er so, yeah, we are living the future. Und da war dann irgendwie dieser Begriff geboren und dieses Gefühl, was wir hier versuchen, die ganze Zeit einzufangen.
03317097160, hattet ihr ähnliche Erlebnisse? Martin, grüße dich, guten Abend.
Ja, so ähnliche Erlebnisse hatte ich. Das ist im Prinzip zwar ein relativ subtiler Gerät und ein Vakuum-Tablett, so ein Stift-Tablett zum Zeichnen für ein PC. Aber es macht irgendwie sehr viel Spaß und die Ergebnisse sind wirklich nicht schlecht. Also, es ist ein kleines handliches Tablett, ein Stift, sieht eigentlich aus wie ein ganz normales Stift. Und ja, wie man malt, sieht man am PC. Ist aber sehr feinfühlig, man kann auch ein bisschen härter einstellen. Und vor allen Dingen, das Beste ist, man hat halt nicht mehr 100.000 Blätter rumzulegen.
Die man dann irgendwann scannen muss, oder du hast auch nicht diesen, weiß ich nicht, die Maus auf dem Bildschirm, die sich auch ein bisschen, nicht so unanatomisch dann bewegt, wenn man Dinge zeichnen will.
Vor allem, probier mal mit einer Maus, irgendwie einen Kreis zu zeichnen oder so.
Das ist ja schon...
Den gibt es doch voreingestellt, ich weiß ja.
Also, es geht vor allen Dingen halt darum, Sachen zu malen, die jetzt eben nicht so perfekt wie auf einem Computer aussehen. Also, keinen Kreis zu malen, der absolut perfekt ist, sondern halt...
Der schön ist...
.ein bisschen organisch zum Beispiel. Also mal relativ viele Charaktere und da sollte halt ein bisschen organisch aussehen. Kriegt man halt schnell aus der Hand so hin. Und der Stift gut in absolut gerade Linien, kann man damit nicht zeichnen, das geht halt nicht. Hat doch noch so ein paar kleine Nachteile halt. Da ich nicht viel Geld hab, kann ich mir jetzt nicht irgendwie ein Tablett, so ein Stifttablett kaufen, wo schon ein Display mit drin ist. Also das hat wirklich einen Nachteil, weil man muss immer auf den Monitor gucken und ein bisschen intuitiv arbeiten. Aber trotzdem ist schon top. Also da hatte ich mich jetzt auch schon erkannt, das ganze Hiebs noch für 3D. Also sprich, dass man noch skulpturieren kann am Computer und das läuft dann irgendwie mit so einer Art Kran. Und ja, damit kann man dann mit diversen 3D-Programmen halt auch noch, also nicht komplett 3D-Modelle erstellen, aber gut nachbearbeiten.
Okay, das sind jetzt technische Features. Wie ging es dir dabei? Also ich meine, was war jetzt so dein Feeling, als du auf dieses Gerät gestoßen bist?
Ich höre aus deiner Erzählung Martin, dass du als Grafiker arbeitest, mit Zeichnen zu tun hast und dir das in irgendeiner Form das Leben leichter macht.
Ja, also sagen wir mal, es ist noch ein Hobby. Und ich habe es mir irgendwann zugelegt, einfach mal um zu testen, eben weil ich hier relativ viel Papier rumzufliegen hatte. Wenn ich mal auf dem PC gemacht habe, war es halt ein Kreis, also relativ genau zu arbeiten, ein paar Muster oder sowas. Und wollte ich mal ausprobieren, so meine Sachen, die ich normalerweise auf Papier zeichne, auf dem PC zu zeichnen. Und ja, dann hatte ich hier halt das Programm Photoshop. Das kommt der eine oder andere.
Gab's da, Entschuldigung, wenn ich da kurz irgendwie reingereiche, gab's da bestimmt einen Moment, wo du gesagt hast, und jetzt muss ich es probieren, jetzt will ich mal was anderes machen? Ist dir das Papier vom Schreibtisch runtergefallen?
Ja, genau. Also ich war irgendwie der Meinung, es muss mal was anderes sein. Und war dann relativ spontan gekauft. Einfach jetzt muss ich mal was ausprobieren. Also das hat jetzt auch nicht die Welt gekostet.
Versuchst du denn auch andere Leute davon zu überzeugen, wie geil diese Technologie ist? Hast du das auch schon mal gehabt, dass du merkst, dass du dich mit irgendwelchen Leuten unterhältst, in denen du wirklich auf Teufel komm raus jetzt überzeugen musst, wie cool diese Technik ist?
Zumindest die Leute, die skeptisch waren, ob man mit so einem Tablett überhaupt zeichnen kann auf dem PC, die hab ich überzeugt. Und, also ansonsten, ja, mein Vater war beeindruckt, dass das denn so geht und, ja, also...
Ansonsten ist es wahrscheinlich wie bei vielen anderen technischen Sachen, im Moment bist du eine der wenigen, die wissen, dass es sowas gibt, und die finden es super. Und dann in 20 Jahren hat es die ganze Welt und du sagst...
Ich denke, das nutzen schon viele, aber für mich war es halt der technische Fortschritt. Ist halt auch ein anderes Gefühl, wenn man am PC zeichnet. Ist irgendwie komisch. Man sitzt halt auf seinem Stuhl und guckt auf dem Monitor. Ist jetzt nicht so diese auf dem Tisch Lampe an, sondern ist halt ganz anders.
Also Stifttablett als den Technik-Flash. Danke Martin. Schönen Abend. 03.3.1.7797.110. Was hat euch technischerweise aus den Socken gehauen? Was hat euch beeindruckt? Hallo Jens. Du rufst von wo an?
Ich ruf aus Nienburg an. Das ist zwischen Hannover und Bremen.
Okay. Was hat dich geflasht?
Ah, der erste Flash, eigentlich waren es drei. Der erste Flash war der ZX81 von Sinclair.
Das ist ein komischer, gnubbiger Computer mit komischen Gummitasten, weil man denkt, den kann man einfach problemlos in die Waschmaschine stecken.
Er hatte nicht mal Gummitasten.
Er hatte einen Kilobyte. Ein bisschen mehr Respekt bitte.
Genau. Es war ein kleiner Türstopper quasi. Und den hab ich zum ersten Mal gesehen, überhaupt als ich begriffen habe, was überhaupt ein Computer sein kann. Und der begeistert mich eigentlich immer noch. Ich arbeite auch noch damit. Teilweise sogar. Ich bin auch in einer aktiven Usergruppe.
Du arbeitest mit einem ZX81?
Was arbeitest du denn da?
Das ist Living The History.
Na ja, also mein Telefonregister hab ich da drin. Also Adressen, solche Sachen.
In einem Kilobyte?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Sondern du hast die 64K-Arbeitung?
Ich hab die 64K-56, kann man nutzen, klar. Und Diskette dran. Die 64 Floppy, also sowas.
Ich hab grad das Bild.
Wie sich zwei Leute treffen, der eine hat irgendwie einen alten Käfer und der andere hat einen alten Zünder und die sagen beide, oh guck mal, die Schraube hast du auch schon dran.
Es gibt noch Aktive, also. Das ist doch mal ein Internet-Zoom, ganz einfach. Aber der zweite Flash, den ich hatte, war Datenübertrag mit dem Commodore 64 per Akustikuppler. Dass ich eine Mailbox in Amerika erreicht habe und dort halt auch Daten austauschen konnte und das fand ich ein absolut erhebendes Erlebnis. Das war, der ZX81 kam bei mir 82 und der Commodore kam 83, gleich ein Jahr danach. Und Datenübertragung hab ich gemacht 85, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, das ist aber auch wirklich so ein, was uns hier alle, was wir alle gemeinsam haben, ein prägendes Erlebnis war einfach, diese Datenverbindung, sei es jetzt Akustikuppler oder Modem und das erste Mal auch so live mit jemanden zu chatten. Also da ist jemand, ich schreib mir jetzt mit dem und ich weiß wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal, wie der aussieht. Hab keine Ahnung, wer der ist, aber jetzt schreibt er mit dem jemand, was unter passiert ist.
Auch Leute kennenzulernen, die sich für die gleichen Dinge interessieren und dass man praktisch ein Netzwerk findet, wo Leute sich finden und was sonst gar nicht möglich wäre.
Du hast, warte mal, du hast 85 dich mit deinem Akustikuppler in eine amerikanische Mailbox eingeloggt.
Das heißt, du hast einen Klärgespräch in die USA gewählt?
Ja.
Was hast du dann dafür bezahlt in dem Monat?
Also es war danach auch erst mal eine Zeit lang kurz vorbei. Ich musste dann noch ein paar Jahre warten, aber...
Kannst du da so mal finanziell eine Hausnummer ansagen, was sich das gekostet hat?
Ich glaube, die Rechnung war damals bei 500 Mark und das hat mein Vater sehr gefällt. Aber es hat Spaß gemacht.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Aber hättest du dir echt locker Geld sparen können, da fällt mir nämlich auch noch so ein Living The Future Moment ein. Genau aus der Zeit. Man konnte nämlich damals kostenlos telefonieren, indem man immer die Vorwahl mitgewählt hat. Aber anstatt der Null eine 11. Man musste halt 11 Impulse schicken anstatt 10 Impulse. Damals hatten wir ja noch Impulswahl. Ihr wisst schon so Wählscheiben. Genau, eine Null macht halt 10 Impulse. Aber wenn man halt 11 Impulse hinbekommen hat, dann war das sozusagen der Testanruf des Installateurs bei neuen Telefonanrufen. Und wenn du dann das geschafft hast, brachtest du also nur ein Finger nehmen und dann 11 mal auf der Gabel rumhämmern, einfach so halbwegs konstant, dann war es kostenlos.
Ist ja großartig.
War super.
Warum hast du mir das damals nicht erzählen müssen?
Hättest du das Handbuch für Hacker lesen müssen.
Ja, verdammt.
Das war der zweite Flash.
Doch war der zweite Flash. Und der dritte Flash war eigentlich schon eigentlich eine Computergrafik von Pixar, die Filme von Pixar, die Shorts.
Welche meinst du jetzt?
Ja eigentlich alles. Es fing mit Wollibee an und ging dann weiter über Nick-Nack und das war dieser kleine Schneemann, der da in dieser Kugel sitzt und nicht aufwärmen. Und das hat mich begeistert, nicht auch wegen des Witzes natürlich, aber auch wegen der grafischen Möglichkeiten, eine Welt im Computer zu erschaffen, die praktisch nur durch Mittel zugänglich sind, wo Leute sitzen, die es halt können. Also ich hätt's damals nicht gekonnt und ich verzweifle immer noch am ZX-81 mit der High-Res Grafik, aber das ist halt so eine Welt gewesen, für die ich mich damals sehr interessiert hab und das fand ich also ein absoluter toller Moment und was heute so im Film möglich ist, ist ja heute schon normal, dass da Computer Grafik drin ist.
Aber das hat man mit diesen Dingern von Pixar, hat man das nämlich irgendwie schon gefühlt, ne? So ging es mir auch.
Das Erlebnis ist eigentlich das Wichtige, dass man etwas erfährt und dass man zum Beispiel, ich beziehe das jetzt nochmal kurz auf den ZX81, der hat vier bzw. fünf Chips, die eigentlich relativ einfach zu verstehen sind.
Zwei haben Paprika und einer hat normalen Kartoffelgeschmack.
Also ICs meine ich.
Der ist klar.
Ja logisch. Man hat dadurch die Möglichkeit, diesen Computer zu verstehen. Ich bin zwar noch nicht so weit, dass ich jetzt sagen kann, ich verstehe ihn komplett, aber man kann ja das so weit runter brechen auf 0 und 1, bis man irgendwann auf Low- und High-Pegel kommt. Und da habe ich mich dann auch mit beschäftigt. Und da gibt es sicherlich andere, die da mehr Bescheid wissen, aber das zu verstehen, diese Komplexität dieses kleinen Computers und dann doch die Simplifizierung, also wie einfach das doch im Endeffekt ist, das hat mich total begeistert. Und das war so ein Moment, wo ich gesagt habe, hey, daraus kann was werden. Und die Leute von Pix haben nichts anderes gesehen. Die haben ja auch die Zukunft, die haben gesagt, wir müssen nur schnellere Maschinen haben. Und dann geht das.
Und wer weiß, wo es hinführt. Das waren jetzt drei Flashes von Jens aus Nienburg. Vielen Dank. Wir kommen jetzt von ganz früh zu was relativ Neuem, nämlich von Gordon aus Ludwigslos. Hallo Gordon.
Guten Abend.
Hast du ein Wort von dem verstanden, was Jens gerade erzählt hat?
Das ging mir eigentlich alles viel zu schnell.
Ja, aber ein schneller Redner. Na dann mach so mal ganz...
Was ist dein Living The Future Erlebnis?
Also mein Flash, das war letztes Jahr zu Weihnachten, wo ich die PS2 bekommen hab. Da hab ich mich erstmal total gefreut. Ich fand die Technik ganz toll.
Was hast du bekommen?
Eine Playstation 2?
Ja, richtig.
Das ist auch uralt.
Na ja, ich dachte, du hättest schon eine Playstation 3 bekommen.
Natürlich ist die Playstation 3 jetzt besser, aber im letzten Jahr fand ich diese Technik ganz toll, die Grafik. Das hat mich total geflasht, sag ich mal. Das war einfach ganz toll.
Das war der letzte Flash hier. Das war der erste, kann sich daran erinnern, wo du ein Gimmickerlebnis hattest, wo du mit großen Augen staunend dasteinst?
Ja, als ich beim ersten Fernseher gekommen hab. Das war so ein Kleiner, der hatte aber schon Farbe. Das war noch nicht so ein Alter, aber der wurde noch mit D-Mark bezahlt, obwohl das gar nicht wichtig ist. Aber das war so auch der mit allererste Flash, dieser erste Fernseher im eigenen Zimmer. Das war echt große Freude.
Also Playstation und der erste eigene Fernseher. Gordon, das ist ein Beitrag, der so quasi auf der anderen Seite der ganzen ZX81 Chip Peeper Pro des Universums steht. Deswegen vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Achso und was mich noch ganz toll freut, obwohl ich auch immer drüber nachgedacht hab, was man noch zum Beispiel machen könnte, so Roboter an Kassen, die einem die Sachen einpacken oder auch auspacken, das wäre doch eine tolle Idee.
Das wäre doch mal was Witziges.
Na dann auf in den Bastelkeller, erfinde einen und dann nächstes Jahr deine Erfindung, die die Welt verändert, glücklicherweise. 0331 70 97 110. Chaosradio auf Fritz im Blue Moon, der nächste am Telefon ist, das kann ich nicht entziffern. Hallo, wie heißt denn du? Da ist gar keiner mehr. Schade, das ging ums iPhone. Vielleicht jetzt weg. Gut, dann reden wir mit Paul. Hallo Paul.
Hallo, schönen guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend. Du rufst an aus?
Berlin.
Richtiger Antwort.
Und dein Flash.
So.
Mein ersten Flash hatte ich 1995. Und zwar, ich hatte einen Bericht über eine Tapete, also sprichte Papier, die per Strom ihre Farbe ändert.
Also du hast einen Fernsehbericht darüber gesehen.
Ja, der Fernsehbericht, also natürlich, weil die Wand noch nicht ausgelesst, die Tapete noch nicht ausgelesst. Aber sie hat die Möglichkeit, kleine Moleküle, die oben schwarz und unten weiß sind, zu drehen. Die sind so klein, dass man mit dem bloßen Auge den Farbunterschied erkennen kann.
Das ist so wie das E-Paper, so wie das elektronisches Papier.
Das war damals noch in der Entwicklung.
Das würde bedeuten, dass die Wand, die irgendwie in so einem Alabasta-Weiß gestrichen wird, auf Handschlag sich in ein Lindgrün ändert?
Ja, die Verwendung war eben so gedacht, dass man eben eine Zettungsblattpapier in der Hand bekommt, in einem per USB-Stick aktualisiert und dass die Kühechen so drehen, dass eine neue Schrift und Bilder erkennbar sind.
Ein elektronisches Papier. Gibt es mittlerweile schon, hätte ich mal auch gedacht, dass so eine Geschichte noch kommt. Wir haben auch mal bei uns im CT-10 ein bisschen umgefragt und da meinten auch schon Leute, die benutzen das jetzt schon. Das ist jetzt, sag ich mal, unter den Geeks, unter uns die Leute, die jetzt wirklich sagen, okay, wir sind jetzt schon so einigermaßen auf dem neuesten Stand der Technik und da benutzen sowas auch Leute schon. Das heißt, die haben dann da ihr kleines Gerät und das war natürlich auch die Vision, wo man sagt, okay, das ist jetzt ein Buch und ein Buch hat einen Ausschalter. Ganz normal für uns, klar, es ist halt ein E-Book. So und da lädt man dann irgendwelche neuesten Bücher drauf, seien es irgendwelche Bedienungsanleitungen, aber auch Geschichten, alles Mögliche. Und dann kann man mit dem Ding bequem lesen. Ist also deutlich angenehmer als auf einem Laptop Bildschirm oder auf sonst irgendwie einem Display, weil es einfach diese harten Kontraste hat, wie ja so diese Kügelchen. Das ist glaube ich auch bei den E-Books, bei den aktuellen, das Verfahren, was auch noch mal genommen wird. Das heißt, man hat also wirklich eine sehr, sehr feine, sehr kontrastreiche Schrift. Idealerweise sind die Dinge ganz leicht, sind groß und bieten auch irgendwie eine Bedienung, die auch so ein bisschen an so einen Seitenumblättern erinnert.
Aber was Paul ansprach, die Anwendung als Tapete, ist zwar Quatsch.
Das ist ein bisschen teurer Spaß, glaube ich.
Ja, aber das, dass du das vor zehn Jahren gesehen hast, finde ich interessant, weil das ist eigentlich so, gerade jetzt auch Schwärmen kommen, wo LEDs relativ günstig werden, Medienfassaden, dieser ganze Bim-Bim, das ist jetzt gerade der totale Hype.
Es wurde letztens vorgestellt eine Cola-Dose, die mit so einem LCD-Bildschirm umranget wurde und wo die Werbung sich drumherum bewegt. Also wie so ein kleiner Fernseher um eine Cola-Dose, die man rumwickeln konnte.
Genau, man kann keinen iPod mehr, kann man einfach, muss sich eine Dose ziehen.
Aber es ist auch mal interessant, wie diese Illusion oder die Vision von Technik, wie sie sich entwickelt, so weitergeht. Da haben die Leute gesagt, geil, wir machen eine Tapete. Und jetzt ist halt ein elektronisches Buch draus geworden.
Ja, es war damals, wo es die Vorstellung, was man damit halt machen könnte, sowohl übereingesetzt werden könnte.
Also, natürlich ist das mal so.
Absurd ist es zwar nicht, aber es waren damals so diese Philosophien, wo man es einsetzen könnte, um damit den Glauben zu machen. Ja, und obwohl ich dann die nächsten Sachen gesehen hab, die mir sehr überrascht haben, war 2003 als Quicks, nee, O'Neill die erste Jacke vorgestellt, also das haben mehrere Firmen gemacht, aber O'Neill hat das auch vorgestellt. Eine Jacke mit einem eingebauten MP3 Player und Bluetooth Headset in der Jacke, also mit Kopfhörer, Freisprechanlage und so.
In der Jacke?
Das sind so Snowboarder-Jacken, oder?
Und dann läuft es rum wie MacGyver. Und darfst du niemals waschen und dich damit nicht auf die Nase legen, weil sonst irgendein Kabel bricht.
Ja, aber die Anwendungskasten waren nämlich alle an der Hand mit Ranne. Man wollte nicht erst irgendwo in irgendwelchen Taschen den MP3 Player unten aus der Tasche rauswühlen und dann weiter suchen, sondern man hatte gleich immer alle parat.
Aber im Gegensatz zum E-Paper, was von der Tapete sich zum Buch transformiert hat, ist aus der MP3 Player-Jacke nicht so viel geworden. Wer weiß, was da noch kommt.
Diese Variables sind, sag ich mal, unter Militärtechnik mittlerweile groß im Kommen, dass man sagt, man will die Soldaten im Kampfverhältnis auch mit den aktuellen Informationen versorgen. Und die sollen dann auch irgendwelche Computern mit sich rumtragen. Die sind also mittelmäßig von begeistert, aber im Prinzip die Entwicklung geht auch schon weiter. Und da ist es auch mal wieder so, dass die Militärtechnik da natürlich auch einen entscheidenden Beitrag zu bringt.
Weil da wahrscheinlich auch das meiste Geld für die Forschung steckt, das auch, ja. Paul, vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Und zwar, da sie viel über das iPhone geredet wurde, halte mir kurz, was es für Alternativen gibt. Und zweitens von THC, den i200. Das ist ungefähr so groß wie ein Schreibblock. Ach so, ich dachte, wie ein Schreibtisch. Das ist ein 3-Pack PC mit USB und so ein Touchscreen, wo man auch richtig drauf schreiben kann, den durch alle Computer, also mit Windows Business läuft, Windows Lister Business läuft und den durch alle Anwendungen, wie normaler PC hat.
Aber so ein PC ist mir ja gewohnt, da ist ja nichts Neues bei eigentlich.
Ja, aber wir machen jetzt...
Wir sind aber schon kleiner.
Paul, Entschuldigung, wir wollen jetzt nicht so sehr über Devices reden, sondern wir wollen jetzt ein bisschen mehr über die Momente reden. Ja, danke für deinen Anruf.
Reden wir mal mit Tech. Hallo, du bist gerade aus der Leitung geflogen, jetzt bist du wieder da.
Ich wollte meine Erfahrung mit dem iPhone-Kund tun. Und zwar war es für mich so, früher immer so ein bisschen online sein müssen, unterwegs und bin dann halt relativ zwangsgedrungen, weil es halt keine vernünftigen Gewalt so groß gab, auf so ein HTC Trinity mit so einem blöden Windows-Mobile rumgestiegen. Und das war halt dann wirklich unusable. Und jetzt, wo das iPhone dann rauskam, ich hatte vorher schon die Gelegenheit, mit dem Telefon mal zu spielen. Es war einfach der Wahnsinn. Man muss sich überlegen, man schaltet das Ding ein und man kann tatsächlich mit dem Ding telefonieren, ohne sich groß Gedanken zu machen, dass das Ding jetzt wieder in den nächsten zwei Minuten abstürzt.
Aber was war jetzt dein Living The Future-Moment?
Außer, dass man mit dem Telefon telefonieren kann, was ja nicht so in die Zukunft ist.
Ja, das ist ja selbstverständlich so gesehen. Und wenn man jetzt überlegt, das Telefon, man schaltet es ein, es hat eine wahnsinnige GUI. Es funktioniert einfach so, wie man es sich denkt, auch vor allem von der Gestaltung her. Wenn man es jetzt von den Windows-Mobile-Teilen kennt, Stift rausholen, Nummer wählen, Anrufen beim iPhone, eingeschaltet, Liste durchgescrollt und der Anruf steht. Und das ist einfach, denke ich, eine ziemlich revolutionäre Sache dafür. Ein kleines Mobile-Gadget, sag ich mal.
Isst du morgens auch Äpfel?
Nein, ich hab zwar jetzt einen Mac auch, ja. Aber vorher hab ich immer Linux-User gewesen und bin auch so ein bisschen die Technik gewöhnt darunter. Und beim iPhone ist es halt auch so, ich brauch eine Shell und hab das Ding dann auch mit diesem Jailbreak aufgemacht. Hab dann jetzt auch noch eine Shell drauf, was das Telefon einfach noch für mich immer mehr aufwertet und dann auch nochmal dieses Aha-Erleben hat. Internet, Mobile und dann noch SSH auf dem Server. Das ist schon toll.
Wir wollen nicht so sehr über Geräte reden, sondern wir wollen eigentlich über Momente reden. Das iPhone kennen wir jetzt alle. Kannst du noch einen Moment aus deinem Leben beitragen, wo du irgendwie die Zukunft erlebt hast durch Technik?
Die Zukunft durch Technik? Die Zukunft durch Technik waren meine ersten Erlebnisse mit der Unix-Suiden-Schiene. Also vorher so DOS, Windows 3.11 und dann die Möglichkeiten des Unix dann mal erleben. Und vor allem auch dann Nutzen hat einem ein Weltende eröffnet damals. Und das war dann wirklich für mich so der Moment, zu sagen, boah, da geht die Entwicklung hin. Das braucht der Mensch. Also von der Entwicklung her und auch vor allem von der damals Benutzbarkeit, ich weiß nicht, für mich war es toll. Ich weiß nicht, wie es für andere ist, aber das war so für mich der Moment zu sagen, das wird in zehn Jahren jeder benutzen.
Wenn ihr auch so eine Momente habt, dann ruft das an 0331 70 97 110. Danke dir, Tech. Gerüchten zur Folge soll Steve Jobs ja passen zum nächsten Frühjahr am Osterei arbeiten. Wir können den ja leise ein bisschen unten drunter laufen lassen. Chaosradio 130 mit Tim Frank. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, grüßt euch ganz herzlich. Wir reden über den schönen Begriff Living The Future, den Tim geprägt hat, Momente, wo ihr in technischer Hinsicht von Geräten, Dingen, Entwicklungen total aus den Socken gehauen wart, und darüber wollen wir heute reden.
Frank muss mal sagen, was er mit dem Vokum gesehen hat.
Ich hab eigentlich mal auch mal eine Negativ-Story, das heißt also was hat mich sozusagen negativ geflasht. Das war mal, als ich mal einen Mietwagen hatte. Der war halt total top modern, und ich hab halt nicht mehr so einen Autoschlüssel in die Hand gedrückt bekommen, sondern irgendwie so ein komisches Plastikteil. Und dieses Plastikteil muss sich irgendwie ins Armaturenbrett reinstecken. Dann gab's einfach so einen roten Knopf, hab ich drauf gedrückt, dann macht das irgendwie Klick Klick, dann bewegen sich so ein paar Zeige im Armaturenbrett. So und dann dachte ich, okay, und jetzt? Und dieses Auto war auch komplett schallgedämmt und ruhig, und ich merkte auch nicht, dass es irgendwie an war oder so. Und es war irgendwie so ein, dann auch als ich mal losgefahren bin, war es irgendwie so ein Gefühl, also nicht man fährt irgendwie so ein Auto, sondern es ist mehr wie man bedient so ein Stück Software und es ist irgendwie wie in so einem Simulationsspiel, so ein Rennspiel mit so einem Joystick in der Hand. Und irgendwie es gab irgendwie keinerlei mechanische Rückmeldung oder so von diesem Auto. Und es war, wie man saß da irgendwie, kam sich so ein bisschen so komisch vor, als wenn man irgendwie in so einer Simulation ist. Und das war eigentlich mal so ein Negativflash, was ich mal hatte. Ansonsten erfreue ich mich ja auch mal an den kleinen Dingen des Lebens. Ich habe irgendwie ganz lange mich einem neuen Telefon verweigert, weil ich es auch mal blöd finde, mich dann wieder so lange irgendwie vertragsmäßig zu binden und habe mir jetzt aber mal dann doch irgendwie so was ganz Neues, kleines Schickes gekauft und habe mir da so eine Applikation Google Maps oder Google Earth mal draufgetan, zusammen mit einem kleinen GPS-Empfänger, der also meine aktuelle Position erkennen kann und eine Datenanbindung. Es ist so wie im James Bond Film oder wie damals bei Night Rider. Das heißt, ich sag jetzt, mach dieses Telefon, geh da irgendwie in ein Menü, sag jetzt irgendwie starte mir die Applikation und dann zeigt es mir an auf einem Satellitenbild, wo ich gerade bin und ich kann irgendwie reinzoomen und kann also die Umgebung um mich herum erkunden. Und das ist ein Boar.
Du kannst dir von oben angucken, dass du auf einer Straßenecke stehst und auf dein Telefon guckst.
Das wäre dann noch die nächste Stufe, aber das kommt bestimmt auch bald. Aber das ist wirklich dann so wie im James Bond Film oder wie bei Night Rider. Das wünsche ich mir auch, dass ich irgendwie so eine komische Armanduhr habe, wo ich sage, Kid, fahr das Auto vor die Tür. Und das wäre nochmal so ein Yes erhebend.
James Bond ist ein gutes Stichwort.
Da sind auch tolle Sachen dabei.
Da sind immer solche Sachen drin. Genau diese Sachen, er steht irgendwo in der Pampa mit seinem Auto und dann hat er auf einmal so ein Navi-System in seiner Konsole und das zeigt genau mit Piep, Piep, Piep, Piep, wo er ist. Und ich weiß noch ganz genau, wie ich das als Kid gesehen habe und mir dachte so, was denn das für ein Scheiß, das funktioniert ja überhaupt nicht.
Dafür gibt es überhaupt gar keine Infrastruktur.
Ich hatte vollkommen recht, was den damaligen Zustand betrifft, aber so, ich weiß nicht, so richtig drüber nachgedacht, dass das nicht mehr so weit weg sein könnte, habe ich nicht. Also so Satelliten. Ich glaube, ich habe es eher für unmöglich gehalten in dem Moment.
Es gab ja, und damals sind wir bei Bond-Filmen ein schönes Thema, es gab ja auch einen dieser, ich glaube, das war Moonraker oder Goldfinger, einer von denen, die irgendwie alle Woche mal wiederholt werden, wo Leute in so eine, wie so ein Kleiderwagen, bei so Interhotels, bei großen Hotels, sich so reinstellen, also wie so eine Schubkarre mit so einem Gerüst oben drüber, da sind zwei Raketen hinten dran, die kannst du ziehen, damit kannst du ein Stückchen fliegen. So was gibt es ja auch, so was ist ja wirklich gebaut und getestet worden. Das war ja kein Schnickschnack, den die sich da ausgedacht haben. Nicht, dass ich mich jemals darum reißen würde, mit so einem Ding irgendwie durch die Gegend zu fliegen. Aber es ist schon abgefahren, was da gebaut wird. Aber James Bond auch nur am Rande als Thema. Wir kommen jetzt zu was, wo ich weiß, dass Tim sich total drüber freut. Nämlich der Anruf von Daniel, wenn er sein Radioliser macht. Hallo Daniel.
Ja, nee, das war das Telefon, hatte ich auf freisprechend.
Daniel, wenn auf meinem Monitor, was da steht, wenn das stimmt, wenn du mir das jetzt erzählst, dann freue ich mich auf die Geschichte.
Also das hat mich... Ja, meine heulte Mutter...
Warte mal, pass auf, du bist die Alten, kommst wo her?
Ich bin 24 und komme aus Wolmestädt, das ist in der Nähe von Magdeburg. Ja, also Rand des Fritzinde-Gebietes. Willkommen, so. Ja, meine heulte Mutter hat mich dazu verdonnert, Rasen zu mähen, dabei hatte ich mich an dem Tag gerade so übergefreut, dass mein neuer Router gekommen war, mit WLAN. Ja, und dann habe ich mit dem halt so ein bisschen rumgespielt und ich bin als, darf ich jetzt sagen, iPhone-Hasser, das kann mein Telefon jetzt schon alles, das meiste. Also jetzt war ganz grob. Halt mit WLAN ausgerüstet, vom Telefon her. Und habe dann, damit ich das Rasenmien natürlich auch genießen kann, von meinem Rechner MP3s über meinen WLAN, was er gerade schön eingerichtet hat, auf mein Telefon gestreamt, damit ich MP3s von meinem PC über meinem Telefon beim Rasenmien hören kann. Ja, und das war so, also ich stand dann so im Garten, hörte so meine MP3s, die ich so gerade bei Winamp reingemacht habe, und dachte so, ja, das ist ganz schön technisch. Das ist schon so richtig, ja, also wenn das so weitergeht, dann wird es nur noch besser eigentlich.
Ja, ja, das sind diese schönen Dekadenten-Installationen. Wenn man nur so ein bisschen die Technik im Griff hat, dann kann man irgendwie auch, vor allem wenn man mal zusammenrechnet, was du da sozusagen für einen Warenwert irgendwie zusammengekratzt hast, nur um mal ein bisschen Musik beim Rasenmien zu hören, ist auch schon erstaunlich. Du hättest die sowieso gekauft, von daher ist ja vollkommen okay.
Das Schlimme ist ja eigentlich, es ist eine super komplexe technische Lösung, aber mein Handy hat einen MP3-Player, also auf das Vorspulen der Titel verzichte ich bewusst. Also ich kann dann, oh jetzt habe ich einen falschen Titel in der Playlist, kann ich nicht weitermachen, weil ich streame es ja gerade von meinem PC auf mein Handy. Ja, das werde ich dann wahrscheinlich demnächst machen. Jetzt ist ja Winter, jetzt mal gucken.
Musst du im Winter auch Rasen nehmen?
Nee, aber ich sehe Daniel im Winter quasi im Schuppen verschwinden, wirst du mit einer Thermoskanne Tee und einem Stift hinter dem Ohr und dann so, ich zeichne hier mal noch so ein Modell, mal gucken, ob das geht. Dann kommen irgendwelche abgefahrenen Dinger raus und im nächsten Frühjahr sitzt Daniel, ich wette sitzt Daniel zu Hause, hört seine MP3s mit Füßen auf den Tisch und der Rasenmäher fährt von alleine.
Ja, das wäre das beste dann.
Du würdest ein Programm schreiben, wo du deinen Rasenmäher, den Garten gescannt hast und den Rasenmäher vom Bildschirm aus durch den Garten dirigierst.
Na ja, raus soll es schon gehen. Man ist ja im Rahmen des WLAN auch fähig, sich auch neben den Rasenmäher zu setzen und sich an der wirklichen Effizienz seiner Programmiertätigkeit zu erfreuen.
Die einfache Variante ist, du suchst dir jemand, der diesen Rasenmäher für dich schiebt, du läufst einfach hinten her und hörst Musik.
Aber groß hat man einfach einen Ghetto Blaster genommen und die komplette Kolonie beschallt.
Ja, das ist eigentlich das Schlimme. Es gibt eigentlich so viele, viel einfache Lösungen. Aber das ist auch eine Sache, da hat es mich so richtig geflasht.
Genau, manchmal sind nämlich die richtig dekadenten Installationen erst die richtig cool.
Es gibt da eine Formulierung und die trifft genau zu zwischen Ghetto Blaster und ich streame mir meine MP3s auf meinen Rasenmäher. Das eine ist sportlich, das andere nicht.
Super Geschichte, da fällt mir auch gleich noch was zu ein.
Danke Daniel.
Schönen Abend euch Leute.
Nächster Anruf.
Welche Anrufe haben wir denn da noch?
Im Moment können wir mit Markus reden, mit Rady reden.
Du bist auch immer mit der C.
Sie redet sowieso immer so viel.
Hallo Markus.
Willst du das Tim was erzählen oder willst du was erzählen?
Lass doch erstmal den Tim zu sagen.
Heißt Servus, dass du aus Österreich anrufst?
Ja bitte, ich wohne in Hessen.
Er ist ja auch ziemlich weit weg. Und du hörst uns über was?
Über Webstream. Also im Moment über das Telefon.
Okay, über welchen Webstream?
Über unseren oder den von Fritz?
Okay, super.
Das ist ein Gruß an die Fangemeinde, die sich immer fleißig kümmert, dass ordentlich gestrebt wird.
Ja, ich bin auch sehr dankbar. Okay, also, einmal los. Mein Name ist DeMarcus, ich bin 24 und mich flash Peer to Peer. Also, die meisten werden es von uns benutzen, denke ich mal. Aber ich kann jetzt nicht genau festmachen, wann das angefangen hat. Das wurde natürlich durch die ganzen Flat Rates immer einfacher und durch Breitband natürlich auch. Aber einen Moment habe ich vor ein paar Wochen im Kopf irgendwie, da schickte mir ein Kumpel so ein YouTube Video von diesen berühmten Teaser-Girls, die sich dann immer so mit ihren Brüsten beschäftigen. Das kennt jeder. Ich nicht. Und da war dann irgendein Song zu hören, den er nicht kannte, aber unbedingt haben wollte. Also ich lasse jetzt mal die ganze Copyright-Diskussion außen vor. Er schickte mir also den Titel von diesem Lied und innerhalb von fünf Minuten hatte ich das Lied gefunden und ihm zugemailt von einer Band, von der ich noch nie was gehört hatte, von der er noch nie was gehört hatte. Wir heißen wie? Ach, das muss ich raussuchen, das ist lange her. Auf jeden Fall, also das ist eben das, was mich an Peer to Peer so freut sozusagen. Also ich komme an alles dran, mir erzählt jemand was von einem Film, von irgendeinem Lied, von irgendeiner Band, was auch immer und ich brauche jetzt nicht zu suchen, ob ich da eine Platte aus den 70er Jahren irgendwo in einem kleinen Laden finde, sondern ich kann im Internet gucken und sagen, zack, ach innerhalb von fünf Minuten habe ich das auf der Platte, kannst du mir anhören.
Aber mit Peer to Peer meinst du jetzt eher dein Kommunikationsmodell, wie du mit den Leuten redest, nicht so sehr, wo die das Teilen herkriegen.
Ja eigentlich, ja natürlich. Es geht eigentlich eher darum, dass die Leute kommunizieren und sich das Zeug über die Technologie gegenseitig bereitstellen können. Also ich benutze im Moment dieses tolle Programm Miro, das kennen vielleicht einige, um so Screencasts irgendwie zu verdichten sozusagen. Und das ist halt für mich, das war ein extremer Flash, als ich das vor ein paar Wochen gefunden habe. Weil das einfach die Zukunft des Fernsehens sozusagen ist. Ich kriege mir da meine Sendungen zusammen, die ich mir gerne angucken möchte. Und ich kriege die von anderen Leuten ins Haus reingeliefert sozusagen. Kannst du mir angucken ohne TiWO, ohne gar nichts.
Du musst vielleicht nochmal Werbung machen. Miro heißt das Ding. getmiro.com Und das ist einfach ein ganz ganz einfacher Video Player, womit man so Video Feeds, also quasi regelmäßige Veröffentlichungen abonnieren kann.
Genau.
So was wie Podcasts, aber eben mit Video. Und das ist super einfach zu bedienen, rockt einfach total, funktioniert prima. Kann ich schwer empfehlen.
Gibt es für Linux, Mac und für Windows und funktioniert. Also es gibt auch die öffentlich-rechtlichen Namen, zum Beispiel ZDF, Treisat und so weiter. Die stellen auch teilweise ihre Sachen als Podcast rein. Das kann man sich alles runterladen, alles mit dem Programm. Das ist halt wirklich wie ein RSS-Feed und das ist also für mich auch ein Teil von dieser ganzen Peer-to-Peer-Geschichte, weil man damit einfach viel schneller an seine Sachen rankommt und auch an Sachen rankommt, die man niemals vorher irgendwie gehabt hätte oder keine Möglichkeit. Also wenn ich mir jetzt von einem Freund erzählen lasse, dass die und die Band ein gutes Lied geschrieben hat und ich müsste jetzt erstmal in die Bahn steigen und in meinen örtlichen kleinen Plattenladen fahren, bei uns auf dem Dorf gibt es leider keinen, und da eine Stunde im Regal rum suchen oder dem möglicherweise noch peinlich vorsummen, wie dieses Lied jetzt funktioniert, da gehe ich ins Netz, gebe den Titel ein oder gehe auf, wie heißt das, Zongsa oder sowas, gibt es auch noch Suchmaschinen, und habe das Lied innerhalb von 10 Minuten. Gut, man kann sich jetzt darüber streiten, ob man dafür bezahlen will oder nicht.
Das könnte jetzt sehr lange führen, aber die Diskussion führen wir jetzt mal an der Stelle nicht, ohne das in irgendeiner Form zu werten. Aber du hast schon recht, dass diese, ob jetzt peer-to-peer oder allgemein, diese beständige Verfügbarkeit von schnellem Internet, was ja eigentlich immer da ist mittlerweile, sehr viel Kommunikation einfacher macht, sehr viel Recherche einfacher macht und auch Leute, die in infrastrukturell entlegenen Gebieten wohnen, ihnen trotzdem die Möglichkeit gibt, ganz schnell und ganz fix mit anderen Leuten zu kommunizieren, wie die Geschichte, die Tim erzählt hat, aus New Orleans mit Katrina, dass man da über einen Chat mit Leuten, die auf der anderen Seite der Welt sind, ganz schnell zack, zack, zack kommunizieren kann.
Wenn sie denn DSL haben oder einen schnellen Internetzugang.
Ja, aber auch allein die Fülle der Informationen, die ich damit abgreifen kann. Also ich kann mich ja immer nur bei einem Laden oder bei irgendeinem Kaufhaus darauf verlassen, dass der Einkäufer sich jetzt gerade dafür entschieden hat, diese CD mit ins Programm zu nehmen. Oder ich muss aus den USA irgendwie ordern für 30 Dollar Versandgebühren. Per Peer to Peer gehe ich auf einen Direktvertrieb von dem jeweiligen Label oder von dem jeweiligen Künstler. Und hab das dann einfach. Da hängt natürlich die ganze Infrastruktur mit einem Breitbandnetz dran. Aber allein, dass es diese Angebote gibt, dass ich mir aussuchen kann, also ich mir wirklich selber aussuchen kann, was ich mir denn jetzt angucken will und nicht immer abhängig davon bin, dass jemand für mich so eine Vorauswahl trifft. Also das ist für mich die Zukunft, sag ich.
Ja, da hab ich vielleicht nochmal einen Tipp, vielleicht für dich und auch alle anderen. Es gibt so eine coole Film, wie soll man das nennen? Man müsste es Fernsehserien nennen, es lief bloß nie im Fernsehen, sondern im Internet. Es heißt The Scene. Und handelt von eben dieser Rare Szene, wo halt so Filme früh gerippt werden und so weiter. Und das ist eine total absurde Situation, weil die da einfach 90% der Zeit wird überhaupt nicht geredet, sondern sie sind einfach nur am Chatten. Und man sieht halt, was da auf dem Desktop läuft und so. Das ist extrem spannend. The Scene heißt das einfach. Kann man irgendwie schnell über Wikipedia finden, das ist halt so eine Miniserie. Also welcome to thescene.com ist die URL. Da findet man das 1000 Formaten natürlich auch über peer to peer.
Chaosradio 130, Living The Future 0331 70 97 11.
Hast du dir schon eine Living The Future Geschichte erzählt?
Ich überlege die ganze Zeit, welche der vielen Living The Future Geschichten ich erzählen sollte. Was mich wirklich immer, was mich sehr geflasht hat, war die ganze WLAN Geschichte. Also dass man nicht mehr an einem Schreibtisch sitzen muss und da am Computer sitzen muss.
Den Moment, würde ich sagen.
Du klappst den Rechner irgendwo auf, fährst ihn hoch und weißt, okay, machst du einen Browser, okay, du lädest eine Seite aus dem Cache. Und dann gibst du irgendeine Seite eine, der macht, ne, ne, ne, ne, Spiegelonline ist da. Irgendwo mitten unter einem Baum auf einer Wiese. Leucht's noch Saft? Das hat mich echt begeistert, weil ich bin jemand, der hat so, ich mag so MacGyver Gadgets, also so Dinger, die multifunktional sind, so der typische Letterman-Ausprobierer. Braucht man nie, aber ist immer toll, so was zu haben. Und alles, was irgendwie mich nicht zu Hause fesselt, wo ich also entscheiden kann, was, wo und wie ich das machen will, total spannend, Mobiltelefon, Walkman, MP3-Player, was auch immer, Musik mit in die Welt nehmen und irgendwo das da machen und nicht irgendwo hinrennen müssen und dann umsitzen und warten, das hat mich echt geflasht.
Also ich finde auch so WLANs, das ist Wahnsinn, so Wireless LANs. Das war mein erstes Erlebnis, das war bei uns auf dem CCC-Camp vor, was haben wir jetzt?
99, acht Jahre her.
Acht Jahre her, zack, so eine Karte rein, irgendwie bei 40 Grad auf dem Acker, irgendwie eine grüne Wiese, wo sonst irgendwie Pferde grasen.
Du warst einer von zehn oder so, ne?
Es waren nicht so viele Leute, es waren damals so die ersten Karten gerade, es war auch mal ein Experiment, wir wussten auch noch gar nicht, wir dachten, naja, vielleicht ist wieder so eine komische Technik, die wieder in einem Jahr verschwunden ist und so. Dann haben wir mal so ein Netzwerk aufgebaut, und es war auch großartig, zack, Karte rein, kurz installiert, mal eben schnell, wie das halt so ist. Aber es hat dann irgendwie funktioniert. Ja, dann gab es da irgendwie Internet, man konnte man rumlaufen, man konnte das Ding irgendwie mit zum See runternehmen, man konnte damit irgendwie abends Pizza essen gehen, da auf dem Camp und alles. Man hat einfach sein Internet dabei gehabt, das ist großartig.
Ja, ich glaube, umso mobiler das Internet, umso mehr Zukunft. So, ich meine, wir haben ja hier vorhin vor der Sendung auch irgendwie noch dieses eine Liedchen, was wir noch einspielen werden, so, ja, Scheiße, wo kriegen wir denn das jetzt her? Frank irgendwie zu Hause auf seinem Rechner, gab natürlich noch kein WLAN, also zack, UMTS-Büchse rausgezogen über Bluetooth. Also ja, erstmal kommt das Internet über UMTS ins Telefon, geht über Bluetooth in den Rechner, dann zieht man sich das Pfeil, konvertiert es noch, schickt es dann wiederum per E-Mail raus, irgendwie damit es jetzt hier im Studio lande, damit wir hier auf Knopf drücken können. Das ging aber. Jetzt muss ich spielen. Ja, was war das für eine Scheiße vor irgendwie, was weiß ich, 10 Jahren, als wir mit Chaos Radio angefangen haben?
12.
Chaos Radio ist jetzt übrigens 12 Jahre her. Genau.
Ziemlich genau, ja.
Fällt mir gerade so ein.
Ta-dam.
Ta-dam. 12 Jahre Chaos Radio.
Auspusten.
Genau.
Das war's im Jahre 1993. Fischmop unter der Leitung von Bollesnüther, Dänemark. Und now back to the 60s zu den 64ern und dem nächsten Mörderwurm. Hallo, ich wünsch mir Frogger von der Gruppe Atari.
Ich hab ja einfach mal aus der Kalten so einen Song rausgehauen, und alle so boah, was ist das denn, ey, was ist das denn, ey?
Was soll wir haben? Spax oder Spex aus Braunschweig.
Toller Rapper, lange Zeit, also weniger Musik gemacht in der letzten Zeit, weil ein Großteil vom Hip-Hop sich ja damit beschäftigt hat, entweder sich zu erzählen, dass der andere Scheiße ist, oder aber, dass dein Auto 21 Zoll Felgen hat, und das andere hat 22 Zoll Felgen, und deswegen ist die Kiste besser. Und jetzt kommt Spex um die Ecke und hat diese wunderbare Jill Scott-Heron-Version gemacht, die jetzt auch mal Spiele Revolution, gibt es nur als Demo und bei Fritz zu hören. Ihr seid im Chaosradio 130, Telefon 0331-7797 einsetzen.
So live wie die Revolution.
Da ist nichts abgesprochen.
Das ist jetzt nicht ein toller Untertitel.
Wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, ich kratze hier am Mikro, dann ist live.
Alles.
Kratz mich überhaupt nicht.
Und?
Machen wir's jetzt.
Ja, Zukunft, wa? Hast du noch eine? Wer ist denn als nächstes dran? Frank. Erzähl doch mal eine Zukunftsgeschichte.
Wir hatten noch, wir haben ja noch am Telefon.
Wir haben noch so viele.
Rausgeflogen.
Brüning ist rausgeflogen.
Aber dann sollten wir vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz sagen was zu Frogger, weil das hat ja auch noch ein bisschen.
Das ist die Atari Nummer, die wir vorhin hatten.
Atari Nummer und das war eine Datasette. Und zwar, das sind ja Kassetten gewesen, wo man Daten, Programme drauf gespeichert hat, wie heute auf einer, auf einer Diskette oder.
Das war im Prinzip ein Akustikkoppler für Band.
Ja, oder halt wie eine, wie eine Diskette, die man auf dem Schallplattenspieler legen konnte oder so.
Wir fragen mal.
Das ist ja so cool, diese Idee, dass man sich im Radio Software wünscht und dann wird sie einfach so direkt ausgestrahlt. Und das Interessante ist, dass es das gab. Und zwar, man höre und staune natürlich nicht in Westdeutschland, sondern in der DDR wurde das gemacht. In dieser REM-Radiosendung haben die doch tatsächlich Programme für den KC-85 oder andere Modelle live ausgestrahlt. Hast du das live? Bist du eigentlich...
Wo kommst du eigentlich her? Oztler.
Oztler, wa? Hast du gehört? Hast du nicht gehört?
Ich hab nicht gehört. Du musst dich immer schön House of Hero machen.
Hast du keinen Homecomputer gehabt?
Nee, aber aha. Warte mal, erstmal greife ich in die Telefonleistung und sage schön guten Abend. Wer ist denn da?
Hallo?
Sorry, ich hatte in der Warteschleife gehört, dass noch zwei vor mir dran waren.
Das Internet, das spricht zu uns.
Du heißt wie?
Christoph, ich bin 26 und komme aus Siegen.
Wow, aus Siegen?
Genau.
Und du hörst uns wie?
Normalerweise übers Stream und jetzt gerade übers Telefon.
26, hast du von diesen ominösen Datasetten, die die Opis gerade erwähnt haben, hast du davon schon mal was gehört?
Ja, gut, das könnte natürlich auch ein Flash gewesen sein. Wenn ich damals bei meiner Oma war, da hatte mein Onkel ein C64 und die anderen Kisten alle da stehen. Und da hab ich also die Wochenende freiwillig für meine Oma verbracht, um in dieses Zimmer zu können. Und dann auch, ja, doch das ist tatsächlich auch ein Flash, wie es dann nachher durch die Cd-Rom und alles schneller wurde, weil ich erinnere mich an Batman auf dem C64, hatte eine Ladezeit von 40 Minuten.
Was hat man in der Zeitung?
Und wenn meine Oma der Zeitung kapte, musste ich vor ins Bett. Dann konnte ich das nicht mehr spielen, obwohl das gerade eben erst geladen war.
Dann muss die erste Floppy-Disc die Erleuchtung für dich gewesen sein. Wo das dann alles nur noch zwei Minuten gedauert hat.
Das war krass, das war so schnell. Da haben 170 Kilobyte draufgepasst.
Ja, aber Floppy-Disc hab ich übersprungen. Also meine Freunde hatten alle so einen C64, aber ich hab dann so einen Amiga bekommen, und da war das etwas noch schneller, ganz leicht. Außerdem war die Grafik besser.
Und da gab es dann gleich Festplatten.
Du hast die Disketten komplett übersprungen, richtig?
Mein eigentlicher Flash war, als eben der P2P-Anrufer dran war, da ist mir das wieder eingefallen, dass ich irgendwann mal, als ich meinen Eltern, als ich noch zu Hause gewohnt habe, versucht habe zu erklären, wie toll das Internet ist und was man alles machen kann, damit mich ganz weit aufs Fenster gelehnt haben gesagt. Man kriegt einfach die ganze Musik, die es auf der Welt gibt, auch über den Computer.
Und dann hat Papa gesagt, pass mal auf, es gab irgendwann von Peter Müller den Song Erdbeereis.
So ungefähr, es war etwas schlimmer. Er ist direkt runter in seinen Keller und hat von seinem alten Tonbandgerät so ein Lederbüchstein geholt, wo er dann so die ganzen Tonbänder mit Spurenummern und so eingetragen hat, wie jeder drauf war. Und sagte, hol mal, die krieg ich nicht. Weil egal, in welcher Stadt er ist, geht er immer in CD-Läden und guckt nach seiner Art Songs, das sind so One-Hit-Wonder aus den 50ern. Und dann fing das an, als ich irgendwie noch 4 Stunden Gus Bakus, der Mann im Mond auf meinem Rechner hatte, da war der gute Mann so begeistert von, dass er mich 2 Wochen lang in mein Zimmer eingesperrt hat, gesagt, Telefon ist jetzt mal egal.
Hier, Quatsch nicht, Quatsch nicht, mach, wenn du was zu essen willst, klopfst du an die Tür.
Vorher hieß es immer, blockier nicht die Telefonalterung, das zum Kotzen, wir schaffen das Internet wieder ab. Aber da war es auch einmal ganz okay. Und was mich einfach wirklich fasziniert hat, war, dass ich nach zwei Wochen seine Jugend irgendwie über meine kleine Kiste reingekriegt hab. Das fasziniert mich heute noch.
Plötzlich war das Internet der Freund von deinem Papa?
Ich hatte das auch, als ich angefangen hab, meine alte Musikkassettensammlung aufzulösen und einfach nach und nach reingehört hab, was ist es? Denn teilweise hast du nicht mal so sorgfältig aufgeschrieben, was es eigentlich ist. Man guckt im Internet nach, irgendwie Songtexte-Sammlung gibt da einen kurzen Teil vom Refrain ein.
Die RIAS-2-Moderatoren haben da immer schön hinten drauf gequatscht auf meine Kassetten.
Aber ich hab das ja richtig sauber alles aufgenommen. Ja, und dann nach und nach, eine Kassette nach der anderen, wanderte dann auch in den Müll, weil die Sachen tatsächlich übers Netz da waren. Das heißt, ich hab sie gefunden und auch natürlich bekommen übers Netz. Und das ist großartig. Das stimmt, das kann ich bestätigen. Also jetzt sag ich mal, vom Flash-Faktor jetzt nicht mehr so hoch, aber das finde ich auch schon mal eine ordentliche Errungenschaft.
Ich weiß noch, was das angefangen hat. Da kam ein Kollege zu mir und sagte hier, es gibt jetzt was ganz Neues zur Musik, das ist die Wave nur mit Zit und ich so, äh, wozu braucht man das?
Ich hab so eine Steheranlage.
Dann hatte ich auch anderthalb Jahre lang zwei MP3s. Das eine war diese Man in Black-Zitte-Song. Ja, und irgendwas, ich glaub XLF.
Klar, XLF.
Diese zwei MP3s und wenn ich mir heute überlege, was ich so auf meiner Platte hab an Musik.
Alleine, wie du das erzählst, da gibt es einen Wave als Zip-Down-Fahrt. Ich hab doch eine Serienanlage. Da hatte ich zwei MP3s. Die kriegen dann auch einzelne Namen. Man muss immer mal gucken, wie es ihnen geht. So ein bisschen wie das Tamagotchi. Schöne Geschichte.
Ja, damals hat das immer auch gedauert. Also meine erste CD, die ich gerippt hab, glaube ich, die war über Nacht. Also da war so ein MP3 auf meinem Pentium. 120, irgendwie 60 Minuten oder so. Also das hat noch echt Zeit gefressen damals.
Respekt. Schönen Gruß an den Papa und ich hoffe, dass du dir dieses Jahr für Weihnachten schon eine super, fuchser Jahre Oldiesampler zusammengestellt hast. Schönen Gruß nach Siegen. Wir machen gleich weiter im Chaosradio. 0331 77 97 110. Vorher die Nachrichten.
Kenfm.de Vier Stunden, drei Bands, ein Sonntag. Die vier Stunden sind klar. 14 bis 18 Uhr. Die drei Bands heißen Amos Live, A Song, A Cigarette und Gods of Blitz. Und der ein Sonntag, also der ist ja schon Ende der Woche. Vier Stunden, drei Bands, ein Sonntag. Fehlt nur noch die zwei.
Gott bewahre uns vor Halbidioten.
Kenfm.de Die Fritz-Radio-Show mit Ken Jepsen.
Immer sonntags ab 14 Uhr live in den Fritz-Studios in Potsdam-Wabelsberg.
Auf allen Frequenzen von...
Und das hört man...
Halb zwölf. Mit Matthias Zachow.
In der neuen PISA-Studie schneiden deutsche Schüler offenbar besser ab als in den vergangenen Jahren. Eine spanische Lehrerzeitung berichtete, sie liegen beim Umweltwissen und der Naturwissenschaften in der Spitzengruppe. Sie sind nämlich auf Platz 13 von insgesamt 57 Staaten. Bei der PISA-Studie 2003 war Deutschland noch auf Platz 18. Allerdings kann man beide Tests nicht vergleichen, weil die Aufgabenstrukturen anders sind. Nach der gestrigener Ostkonferenz in Annapolis haben US-Präsident Bush, Palästinenser Präsident Abbas und der israelische Ministerpräsident Olmert heute im Weißen Haus symbolisch die neuen Friedensverhandlungen gestartet. Gestern war vereinbart worden, dass die detaillierten Verhandlungen am 12. Dezember beginnen sollen. Die arabische Liga rief dazu auf, den neuen Friedensverhandlungen eine Chance zu geben. Mit einem Bußgeldkatalog wollen Bund und Länder den Jugendschutz verbessern. Wer Tabak, Alkohol oder Gewaltvideos an Jugendliche verkauft, muss in Zukunft mit bis zu vierstelligen Geldstrafen rechnen. Das sagte Bundesfamilienministerin von der Leyen heute. In Gaststätten und Tankstellen soll es Schwerpunktkontrollen geben. Die umstrittenen Testkäufe von Jugendlichen will die Ministerin nicht mehr bundesweit regeln. Zum Fußball in der Champions League haben sowohl Werder Bremen als auch Schalke 04 ihre Chancen auf die nächste Runde gewahrt. Bremen gewann gegen den spanischen Meister Real Madrid 3 zu 2. Schalke spielte in Valencia 0 zu 0 unentschieden. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Frankfurt 0 Grad, Potsdam Cottbus und Angermünde 1 Grad, Neuropin und Wittenberge 2 Grad und auch in Berlin 2 Grad momentan. Heute Nacht bleibt es trocken. Die Temperaturen sinken bis auf minus 4 Grad. Es kann glatt werden zum Teil. Morgen erst viele Wolken, nur ein bisschen Sonne zwischendurch. Zum Abend hin ist dann Regen oder Spülregen möglich. Die Temperaturen liegen morgen zwischen 3 und 6 Grad. Eine Meldung von der A12 Richtung Frankfurt-Odern. Zwischen Frankfurt Mitte und der Grenze steht ein kaputter Lkw. Hier gibt es Behinderungen, ansonsten euch überall eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Frankfurt Oder.
Brobeli Brobel, Chaosradio 130, Tim, Frank und Jakob im Studio 0331 70 97 110. Living The Future ist das Thema heute. Wir haben eine Menge fantastischer Geschichten gehört von euch zum Thema. Wann wart ihr Zeuge eines Momentes, wo ihr gesagt habt, das ist die Zukunft. Das ist, ich bin gerade Teil des MacGuywaschen. Du hattest vorhin diesen Highlander-Flash.
Genau, aber wo man es auch wirklich so lebt. Also wo man auch echt so das Gefühl hat, so jetzt bin ich irgendwie auch echt Teil davon. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt auch so ein paar Leute gehört, die meinen so, naja, ich habe jetzt so das Telefon, das ist ganz toll und so. Klar, das hat natürlich auch so diese Effekte, aber das hält immer nur so kurz an. Aber was mich immer so richtig fasziniert hat, ist, wenn ich das alles auch so richtig zur Anwendung gebracht habe. Aber wenn diese Geräte nicht nur toll sind und irgendwas versprechen, sondern wenn sie auch ihr Versprechen auch wirklich einlösen und wenn man auch ganz unerwartete Sachen macht. Also was ich zum Beispiel, was ich auch total cool fand, ist auch wieder so ein Erlebnis, was mit dem Chat anfing, irgendwie Maha hier auch aus dem Club, tauchte irgendwie so in meiner Buddyliste auf. Ich saß wieder gerade irgendwo gelangweilt rum zu Hause und sag ich so, Kling, Maha, online, den schnacke ich doch mal an, schon lange nicht mehr gesprochen. Na, altes Haus, was machst du denn und so. Ja, ich habe gerade New York verlassen und befinde mich jetzt irgendwie über dem Atlantik. Ups, also er saß halt mit seinem Laptop auf den Knien und hatte WLAN im Flugzeug. Das war jetzt dieses Connection by Boeing, also so Internet, was mittlerweile abgeschaltet ist, durch demnächst wirklich was Neues ersetzt wird. Und da gab es halt echt ganz gut Bandbreite. Das war wohl für Lufthansa ein bisschen zu teuer, aber sie haben es für relativ wenig Geld angeboten. Ich glaube, er hat so 20, 30 Euro bezahlt. Und ich so cool und so gleich irgendwie alle Tools rausgeholt und dann haben wir erst mal Skype gestartet und dann haben wir uns halt miteinander unterhalten. Also wir hatten richtig so eine Audio-Konferenz.
Wie war die Qualität?
Super. Also es war okay.
Hast du gemerkt, dass er im Flugzeug ist? Also irgendwie am Hintergrund, Rauschen, Brummen, irgendwie so?
Das ist eine gute Frage, aber das kann man selber überprüfen, weil jetzt wird es ja erst richtig cool, weil wir dann beschlossen haben, dann gleich über seinen USA-Urlaub, den er gerade beendet hat, einen Podcast zu machen. Außenflugzeug? Außenflugzeug. Das heißt, ich habe dann über Skype mit ihm einfach geredet, habe das irgendwie bei mir aufgezeichnet und dann waren wir irgendwie nach einer halben Stunde oder so, drei, vier Stunden, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, waren wir fertig, dann habe ich das irgendwie produziert, online gestellt und er hat dann den Podcast auch noch im Flugzeug mit seinem iTunes schon wieder runtergeladen.
Die Leute neben ihm haben bestimmt richtig blöde geguckt.
Der Typ neben ihm, das erzählt er auch irgendwie, glaube ich, in dem Podcast, der hatte irgendwie so ein Windows Laptop und der hat echt blöde geguckt.
Ja, wieso funktioniert denn das bei Ihnen alles so?
Das kenne ich ja gar nicht. Und das war auch wieder so ein Moment, wo ich mir dachte so, boah, wie cool, ja, irgendwie Internet im Flugzeug. Ich wusste den Zeitpunkt schon, dass so Skype-Telefonie ganz gut funktioniert mit der Anwendung, aber dass man das dann halt auch in dem Moment so live zum Einsatz bringt, dass einfach auch die Tools so gut funktionieren, dass man das zum Einsatz bringen kann, fand ich faszinierend. Das war irgendwie auch wieder so Zukunft jetzt hier.
Was ist denn die Frage an die Experten in der Runde? Wie lange wird es denn noch dauern, bis also drahtloses Internet so weit um uns herum ist überall, dass man sich nicht mehr irgendeinen Hotspot suchen muss und da hinrennt?
Das ist ja nur eine Frage der Kosten. Also mit UMTS, bei dem Probeefunkbreiber geht es ja. Es kostet halt nur noch ein Schweine Geld, das ist das Problem. Das Problem ist halt, es funktioniert auch nur so lange, wie es nicht alle nutzen, weil es ist natürlich nicht gut skaliert. Das heißt also, sobald viele Leute anfangen, diese ganzen UMTS-Dienste zu nutzen, ist das Netz auch ziemlich schnell wieder platt. Das heißt, man muss es irgendwie über den Preis regeln, dass es dann nicht doch so viele benutzen.
Es gibt ja diese ganzen technischen Erfindungen und Entwicklungen, von denen wir gerade gesprochen haben, tauchen natürlich immer bei dir als Pop-Flash neu und interessant auf, wenn man es braucht. Also wenn du wirklich gewühlt hast, du kannst damit irgendeine praktische Anwendung, du kannst gerade damit irgendwelche Dinge tun. Wenn nur dein Telefon oder dein Computer einen grünen Ball in einen blauen transformieren kann, dann ja, ok, schön ist es gewesen. Ich erinnere mich an ein Chaos Radio.
Sicher? Also du meinst, dass man irgendwie nur dann Technik annimmt, wenn sie für ein irgendwas Sinnvolles tut?
Nee, aber in dem Moment hast du, glaube ich, einen schnelleren Zugang dafür, wenn du sagen kannst, es hilft mir jetzt in irgendeiner Situation, in der ich was mache. Deinen Podcast mal außen vor. Lass mich mal ganz kurz den Gedanken zu Ende stellen. Also ich erinnere mich an das Chaos Radio zum Thema Global GPS Positioning System, also wie das GPS-System rund um die Welt funktioniert. Wo es darum ging, dass man mit einem relativ geringen Aufwand aus seinem Mobiltelefon ein Navigationsgerät machen kann und sich also diesen ganzen Navi-Blödsinn-Kram klemmen kann oder was extra kaufen muss. Und da sind wir wieder beim Thema Flächendeckendes Internet, worauf jeder zugreifen kann, was Frank ja gerade erklärt hat, wo das Problem dabei ist.
Also ja, diese ganze Telefontechnik finde ich schon gut, weil es ist natürlich auch recht robust. Und ich glaube, bei einem Telefon ist es dann auch noch mal eher einsichtiger für die anderen, wobei es natürlich auch so eine Sache ist, wie die Technik gewachsen ist. Also wenn ich überlege, vor zehn Jahren, wann war das so C-Netz, diese Riesentelefone, da haben mich meine ganzen Freunde schon ziemlich blöd angeguckt, wenn ich irgendwie ein Telefon dabei hatte, was gerade so nicht so ganz an meine Hosentasche gepasst hat. Natürlich heute undenkbar, oder was ich mir an so einem Gurt über die Schulter gehangen habe. Ich hatte später dann das SEM. Das war so das erste Handy in dem Sinne. Das war ungefähr so ein Viertel von einem Schuhkarton ungefähr. Also eher so vom Backstein-Format.
Du meinst das dicke, das Porti?
Nee, das Porti war das Pocky. Das Pocky ist glaube ich das Kleine.
Das Pocky hatte so Ziegelstein-Format.
Genau, das Ziegelstein-Format mit dieser Antenne, die man so zweimal knicken konnte, so falten konnte. Das war das Pocky. Genau, das Pocky, das war das Pocky. Das war dann eher so...
Aber macht mal weiter.
Das sind 10-Netz-Telefone.
Das war so das erste wirklich tolle Mobilfunk.
Das war auch relativ süß. 10-Netz, Pocky, da hab ich noch mit Lego gespielt. Und zwar haben wir das am besten importiert.
Und die Nerds hatten sowas natürlich. Da gibt es ja auch diese schöne Geschichte von Andy.
Der, der irgendwie damals noch als Anfang 20 oder so, oder ein bisschen jünger, zwischen Hamburg und Berlin auch mal getrempt ist und dann irgendwann auch mal mit einem Mercedes-Fahrer gefahren ist.
Vollausstattung, Autotelefon.
Autotelefon, alles mögliche.
Ich hab alles. Und dann fahren sie über die Autobahn und auf einmal macht es Klingelingeling und der Typ greift zu seinem Autotelefon Hallo und es macht Klingelingeling. Und Andi greift irgendwie in seine Plastiktüte rein oder in seine zerstörende Tasche und holt halt irgendwie dieses Porti raus und Hallo und fängt an zu telefonieren. Und dessen Gesicht hätte ich immer gerne gesehen. Aber auch das ist wieder so ein Living The Future. Der wusste wahrscheinlich zu dem Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht, dass man auch ohne Auto telefonieren kann.
So Mobiltelefone sind schon eine ziemlich solide Technologie und da kann man eigentlich auch immer noch ganz gut begründen, wozu man es braucht. Also das ist ja auch mal so eine Sache bei diesen Gadgets, wo den Leute ja schön, aber wozu brauchst du denn das? So und dann muss man schon sich immer irgendwie eine Geschichte ausdenken. Es könnte ja vielleicht und wenn ich denn einsam im Wald stehe und plötzlich das Unwetter kommt oder so.
Aber das ist doch genau das Ding, wo ich eben schon, als du das erwähnt hast, Nerds brauchen das nicht zu brauchen. Die brauchen nur ein Gefühl dafür zu haben, dass das schon irgendeinen Nutzen haben wird. Als ich an mein allererstes Computererlebnis, wo ich so entflammt wurde, war halt auch so der Typ im Laden, der mir irgendwie diesen Rechner gezeigt hat, tippte halt so ein paar Zeilen Code ein und es liefen halt tausend sinnlose Zeichen über den Bildschirm vollkommen sinnfrei und ich dachte mir nur so, das ist es, so, das muss ich jetzt unbedingt sofort lernen. Aber ich kann nicht erklären, dass ich jetzt irgendwie irgendeinen Nutzen da drin gesehen hätte.
Das war pure Faszination.
Die beiden Argumentationen sind glaube ich ziemlich auf der gleichen Linie. Nerds brauchen keinen Anlass oder keinen Grund, jetzt irgendwas dringend erfinden zu müssen, dass man die Brauseflasche einfacher aufmachen kann. Gar nicht. Aber um es sozusagen flächendeckend als technische Revolution in die Welt zu tragen und die Bevölkerung sagt, stimmt, wieso haben wir eigentlich die Räder an unserem Holzkahn früher viereckig gemacht? Rund geht's viel einfacher. Dazu musst du sozusagen ihnen erklären, dass es einen praktischen Nutzen hat, eine Vereinfachung, eine Unkompliziertheit, eine Erleichterung ihres Lebens. Oder?
Ja, hast du recht. Aber Nerds machen häufig ziemlich schlechte Produkte, muss ich feststellen.
Ja, deswegen gibt es ja dann wiederum nicht über das, wie kann man das gebrauchen, sich darüber Gedanken machen, sondern das ist technisch machbar.
Ja, aber es ist doch an sich toll. Also was es für tolle Feature hat, aber dass man dann die nicht anwenden kann, ist eine andere Sache.
Aber was wäre die Welt langweilig, wenn Nerds sowas nicht erfinden würden? Stichwort Blinkenlights.
Das stimmt schon. Blinkenlights.
Womit wir ganz langsam, und die Kurve ist schwer zu sehen, aber ich hab versucht, sie zu kriegen, womit wir ganz langsam zum Kongress kommen.
Von der Location her sind wir nah dran.
Oh nein, das war ja jetzt aber eine Kurve. Oder? Ja, du spielst auf das Motto an. Oder vielleicht spielst du nicht auf das Motto an.
Vielleicht erst mal auf die Veranstaltung.
Genau. Also es ist ja wieder Kongress. Haha, das sagen wir immer im November. Ist bald mal wieder Kongress. Der 24. Chaos Communication Kongress vom 27. bis zum 30. Dezember 2007, wie gehabt am WCC, Berliner Kongresscenter, also am Alexanderplatz, Mütten in Berlin.
Das ist da zwischen Alexa und da, wo die Nadel ist. Der Kulturpickel.
Genau. Und ja, der findet statt, wie immer, mit großem Tamtam und steht dieses Jahr unter dem Titel Volldampf voraus. Ein sehr nach vorne blickender und auch gleichzeitig nach hinten blickender Titel, denn es gibt so, naja, es gibt da so ein schönes Sinnbild, was herangezogen wurde, nämlich das Sinnbild des Steampunks. Sagt ihr das was?
Nee.
Steampunk, das ist so, naja, wie soll man das nennen? So eine kulturelle Bewegung, dass Leute Hightech in viktorianische Kleider gießen. Da hast du dann so Laptops mit messigen Beschlägen und Steampunk sagt ja auch schon, wo es hingeht. Es ist im Prinzip so diese Wiederauferstehung der Dampfmaschine.
Die allerdings mit Hybridantrieb und Brennstoffzelle funktioniert.
Ja, ne oder die einfach nur eine Dampfmaschine ist. Also das Sinnbild, was da bemüht wird.
Das ist aber auch besonders schön dann. Also es geht auch vor allem um Ästhetik dabei natürlich. Es geht nicht so sehr um die Funktion, sondern es geht einfach darum, irgendwie Hightech irgendwie auch schön ästhetisch zu verpacken. Also dieser wirkliche Fetisch dabei ist einfach sehr detailreich, diesen alten Look hinzubekommen.
Genau, aber beim Kongress geht es natürlich eigentlich um was anderes. Der Kongress blickt ja immer auf Technik und Gesellschaft, wie wir das generell tun, und beim Kongress natürlich dann nochmal ganz gezielt. Und das Motto lädt sozusagen ein zum Vergleich dieser beiden industriellen Revolutionen, nämlich der ursprünglichen, die eben ausgelöst unter anderem und vor allem durch die Dampfmaschine, die einfach sämtliche Produktionsprozesse verändert hat, die das Transportwesen verändert hat. Auf einmal gab es Lokomotiven, die einfach unglaublich schwere Lasten von A nach B fuhren konnten. Handel, Produktion, alles war halt komplett dadurch verändert und vor allem auch die Kommunikation, weil die Leute sich eben bewegen konnten und weil man Güter verschicken konnte. Und wir spulen nach vorne. Jetzt haben wir die digitale Revolution, das Informationszeitalter und wieder geschieht eigentlich genau das Gleiche. Auf einmal sind Güter virtuell und Reisen über Datennetze und Dienstleistungen können von irgendwo angeboten werden und das ganze Verhältnis, das gewohnte von Raum und Zeit und von Orten gerät eben aus den Fugen. Und das ist so ein bisschen der Spielball, wo da jetzt beim Kongress thematisch mit rangegangen wird. Ansonsten gibt es natürlich das übliche, die übliche Bandbreite von Vorträgen, technisches, von Security, Programmierung, alles Mögliche, aber auch nicht technisches, kulturelle Highlights, gibt lustige Veranstaltungen und ich bin ja organisatorisch nicht eingebunden, aber das, was ich bisher gehört habe, das sieht super aus und das Programm ist auch schon online.
Und da gibt es eine Liste, wo ich mir angucken kann, wer was machen, damit ich nicht 12 Stunden am Tag da rum sitze und das muss ich auch nicht tun.
Aber es gibt einen Fahrplan, das ist so heiß bei uns, genau, und man muss mal sagen, es ist eine Veranstaltung, da kommen so 2.000 bis 3.000 Leute, das wird also schon ganz schön voll da, ganz schön kuschelig. 4.000 Leute. 4.000 mittlerweile, also insgesamt ja. Und ja, man muss jetzt nicht eigentlich kein Vorwissen mitbringen, es gibt natürlich bestimmte Sachen, die sind jetzt sehr speziell, aber wir bemühen uns auch immer die Bandbreite so zu halten, dass auch Leute, die jetzt nicht die Technik Nerds sind, sondern sich irgendwie nur dieser Sache so ein bisschen hingezogen fühlen, sich da auch wohlfühlen.
Ja und der Kongress ist vor allem echt großer Spaß.
Es ist eine Wohlfühlveranstaltung.
Muss man einfach betonen, es ist einfach fun. Events.ccc.de ist unser Blog zu dem Thema Veranstaltung und insbesondere natürlich jetzt im Kongress. Dort findet man eigentlich alles, was man wissen muss, allerdings.
Und wenn du glaubst, dass du jetzt alle Fragen geklärt hättest, beziehungsweise alle Informationen weitergegeben hättest, dann hätte sich jetzt Nico auf dich.
Ja und zwar, ach, die Fragestellen.
Ja und zwar, ich hab mal vor einer Weile gesehen im Internet so ein schönes Video.
Ihr hattet bei einem eurer Treffen einen Gastredner da und zwar war das irgendwie ein Staatsanwalt, der hat einen Vortrag gehalten zu Hausdurchsuchungen.
Oh ja, der Udo Vetter.
Das war kein Staatsanwalt, das ist ein Rechtsanwalt.
Na oder genau Rechtsanwalt. Auf jeden Fall war das ziemlich lustig.
Das ist der vom vom LawBlock.
Genau, vom LawBlock. Sie haben das Recht zu schweigen, heißt der Vortrag und war mit Abstand der populärste des gesamten Kongresses.
Ja, es war sehr lustig, was er da alles gesagt hat, was sie da alles für Tricks angewandt haben und so weiter. Auf jeden Fall wollte ich euch fragen, ob ihr dieses Jahr auch wieder Gastredner habt, wenn ja, welcher und so weiter.
Ja, schaut doch mal auf events.ccc.de ohnehin.
Also events.ccc.de, der letzte Blockeintrag, zeigt direkt auf den Fahrplan. Die Uhr ist ein bisschen länger. Können wir jetzt hier nicht zusammenfassen, aber ich kann auch schon mal ankündigen, dass es in den nächsten Tagen, in den nächsten zehn Tagen wird es einen Podcast bei Chaos Radio Express geben, also dem Chaos Radio mit ohne Fritz. Und dort gibt es ein Preview für den 24C3. Das heißt, da wird auch so inhaltlich, was so läuft, alles zur Sprache kommen.
Sehr schön. Ja, dann bedanke ich mich für die Auskunft.
Gerne.
Gerne. Ich würde ja jetzt gerne Musik spielen. Hatten wir nämlich beim letzten Mal schon und da gab es einen Haufen nachfragen, was ist das denn gewesen. Der Typ heißt Pete Green mit I haven't got a MySpace because MySpace fucking sucks. Es wird interessant sein zu erfahren, wie nach uns kommende Generationen diese Welt der Social Networking in Verbindung stehenden Websites Xingvz und wie sie alle heißen, das dann sehen werden und sich Geschichten erzählen werden, sagen, guck sie dir an, der Homosapiens damals, die haben sich irgendwie mit ihren Freunden getroffen, obwohl sie ihre Freunde niemals gesehen haben. Komische, merkwürdige Welt. Bringen wir auch noch ein Stück von der Rehkeule mit. Wahrscheinlich wird eine Unterhaltung dann genauso laufen.
Möglich, ja.
Aber darüber werden wir im Chaosradio nicht mehr reden, zumindest nicht mehr in diesem Jahr und nicht mehr heute, denn das Thema ist ein ganz anderes. Living with the future.
Living the future. Mit der Zukunft müssen wir immer leben, aber sie leben selber, das ist natürlich echt ein Unterschied. Wir haben ja gestern im Club auch noch mal ein bisschen rumgefragt, so nach Geschichten, was denn so die Leute so als Living the Future, ich bin echt erstaunt, dass jeder eigentlich sofort was auszugraben hat. Was ich auch noch total cool fand, ist so die Sache mit diesen Telefonbuch-CDs. Irgendwann kamen auch diese Telefonbuch-CDs raus mit so Windows-Gliedern und so weiter. Als die Dinger auf dem Markt waren, haben sich natürlich die Hacker sofort diese Dinger geschnappt und irgendwie versucht, da diese Datenbank-Formate auseinanderzuschneidern und dann dauerte es nicht lange und man konnte halt...
Genau, der Trick war, man konnte natürlich nur Namen eingeben und dann die Telefonnummer dazu, aber man konnte nicht die Telefonnummer eingeben und dann den Namen und die Adresse dazu bekommen. Die Inverssuche, wie es heißt. Genau. Ja und so war es dann auch, wie wir dann mit unseren großen, dicken, zähnetzportablen Telefonen am Bahnhof Zoo standen, nämlich abends, wo die zweite Hand, Kleine Anzeigenblatt, abends dann schon vor Abend rauskam. Ein armer Händler, der da stand und irgendwie 30, 40 Leute stürzten sich auf ihn und rissen ihm diese Zeitung außer Hand. Wir saßen dann da im Auto mit unseren komischen Telefonen und einem alten Laptop, der irgendwie einen riesen Akku mit sich schleppte, wo dann diese einmal umsortierte Telefonbuch-CD drauf war. Das heißt, wir wussten dann auch schon sofort, wo die Leute waren und haben dann teilweise gar nicht mehr die Mühe gemacht, da irgendwie anzurufen, sondern sind dann direkt da vorbeigefahren.
Was wolltet ihr denn kaufen?
Leute, glaube ich, alte Autos oder so, also zum ja, ein bisschen reparieren, aufhübschen, dann wieder verkaufen. Oder wir haben auch alte Telefon-Teile gesucht, gerade Mobiltelefone, wo wir dann aus zwei Stück wieder eins gemacht haben und so was.
Das heißt, ihr habt die Telefonnummer angenommen und nichts anderes stand in der Anzeige? So nach dem Motto Verkaufe, altes Auto, Telefonnummer, hm hm hm.
Genau, Telefonnummer in den Computer eingeben, Adresse zack gleich auf den Weg hingefahren, vielleicht nochmal Anstandszeiten vorher angerufen, vielleicht auch nicht und gleich schon mal irgendwie als Erster da gewesen, zehn Minuten nachdem irgendwie diese Anzeigen zuerst ausfielen. Welches Jahr? Wann waren diese großen Zehnetze Telefone? Das muss so, wann ist die GSM eingeführt worden?
Woher kamen denn diese Telefonbuch-CDs denn raus?
Kurz nach der Christenverfolgung.
Zehn Jahre? Jetzt geht das halt auch ohne sowas. Mit Internet. Das ist doch Zukunft, oder? Ich finde, das ist total zu.
Es gibt, also jeder hat natürlich für sich so einen Moment, wo man so die Glühbirne über dem Kopf aufgehen sieht. Wie die Geschichte, wo Papa sagt, du mit deinem komischen Computer blockierst dir die Telefonleitung. Zeig mir doch mal, was die Büchse kann. Also alles raus, was du willst.
Um nochmal auf den Kongress zu kommen. Also wenn man irgendwie auf so eine Momente, wie wir sie hier schildern, steht, dann muss man echt zum Kongress kommen.
Wenn man das zwölf Stunden am Tag haben will.
Dann kriegt man das nämlich echt am laufenden Meter. Ich meine auch sicherlich auf ein paar anderen Veranstaltungen, aber sicherlich nirgendwo so dicht wie auf dem Kongress. Weil da gibt es immer wieder so Sachen, da klappt mir auch irgendwie so, klappt mir echt die Kinnlade runter.
Vor allem, mit welcher Selbstverständlichkeit so Leute denn irgendwie hier Technik rumschrauben und da basteln und löten und tun?
Hier dieser verrückte Brite, der irgendwie, der ist ja noch gleich, verdammt, ich komm jetzt nicht drauf, der diese Tor-Server analysiert hat. Der hat dann irgendwie, der hat so die Tor-Daten...
Das ist Anonymisierung.
Genau, das ist Anonymisierung. Das heißt, Rechner versuchen komplett anonym zu sein. Dann hat er da irgendwie aus der Ferne gelauscht und irgendwie nur so die Zeitstempel in den Datenpaketen, die da rauskamen, genommen. Und dann hat er das irgendwie zurückführen können, da drauf, wann dort, wo der Computer steht, die Sonne auf und unter ging. Weil es halt tagsüber wärmer ist und sich die Computer ausdehnen und die Zeit läuft dann anders als nachts. Und dann kann er halt auch sehen, wann geht's auf und zu und dann weiß er auch ganz genau, wo die sind auf dem Planeten. Man kann ja wirklich sagen, der ist in der Schweiz, weil er irgendwie Longitude und Latitude einfach da rausrechnen kann. Das ist einfach mal geile Scheiße. So wirklich einfach nur mathematisch da so ranzugehen, find ich super. Ist toll.
Und sowas ist alles beim Kongress zu finden. Ja, sowas ist alles beim Kongress in Berlin.
Genau, weil es so schön ist.
chaosradio.ccc.de, da gibt es auch die Podcasts von Chaos Radio Express.
Richtig.
Und Chaos TV und das Zielkritik, da gibt es auch eine ganze Menge Sachen, da solltet ihr dann mal ein bisschen rumstapfeln.
Und dann ein Wiki zum Mitmachen bei den Sendungen.
Genau, das Blog möchte ich euch nochmal besonders ans Herz legen, weil wir das erst vor kurzem aufgemacht haben und das noch nicht so viele Leute kennen. Wir sind ja immer so ein bisschen zu faul, euch rechtzeitig Mails schicken vor der Sendung, weil wir immer zu was weiß ich, verpeilt oder beschäftigt sind. Eines von beiden könnt ihr euch aussuchen. Aber das Blog ist etwas einfacher zu führen und zu pflegen. Und deswegen tun wir das auch. Und da kann man halt auch zur Sendung, auch zu dieser, kommentieren. Oder eben auch gleich Nützliches in die Mitmachseite zu dieser Chaosradio Sendung eintragen im Wiki. wiki.chaosradio.ccc.de und blog.chaosradio.ccc.de Jetzt hab ich es genug gesagt, oder?
Jetzt haben wir es genug gesagt. Falls ihr noch weitere Fragen habt, schickt eine Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de Ich glaube so oft und in solcher Intensität haben wir lange nicht die ganzen Adressen und Sollen wir sie nicht vielleicht nochmal? Was wir jetzt noch sagen ist, dass es uns extrem viel Spaß gemacht hat heute. Chaosradio 130 vielen vielen Dank. Das nächste Chaosradio kommt im Januar.
Genau, wir machen die Kongresspause.
Genau, denn das letzte beim eigentlich tonusmäßigen Dezember Chaosradio fandet ihr ja der Kongress statt, deswegen gibt es da kein Chaosradio.
Und das nächste Chaosradio Express kommt noch diese Woche und es wird cool.
Was jetzt noch kommt ist der Kollege Martin Petershoff mit fantastischer handausgesuchter Musik. Sowas ist mittlerweile selten im Radio, deswegen euch viel Spaß in dieser Sendung. Wir sagen Tschüss. Und nicht irgendwie gleich Strom und Wechselstrom verwechseln. Wollen wir jetzt nochmal diese Spex nochmal spielen oder wollen wir was anderes spielen?
Welches andere?
Wir spielen jetzt nochmal Spex.
Nochmal das gleiche?
Volle Kanone.
Ist doch langweilig. Cool, ach doch.